i along with many others
had been warning that the ongoing riots
were likely going to corrupt the
criminal trial of derek chauvin
the defense attorney for chauvin begged
the judge to sequester the jury
the judge said no now
i am very impressed with this judge to
now hear him
say that maxine waters threats against
the jury
may be caused to overturn the entire
election
look man i thought judge kale was a
fairly reasonable guy i thought he was
being fair not just given the defense
they wanted but you know going back and
forth and i thought it made sense but
this has to be
one of the stupidest things and one of
the biggest blunders in judicial history
because we know the severity of the
riots we know it affected the entire
country
and the the defense kept saying you need
to sequester the jury and the judge is
like no no it's fine it's fine
and then maxine waters comes out and she
goes if we don't get a first degree
murder conviction which
as you know sheldon wasn't charged with
then we got to get more
more active and get in the streets and
get more confrontational more
confrontational than burning down an
apple store or police station
and uh you know what we saw last year
and the judge now has the nerve to be
like
you know what maybe on appeal the entire
trial will be overturned now
it's almost like it was on purpose so
we're going to talk about this we've got
a bunch of stories surrounding
what's going on with maxine water
statements how it's affecting politics
but we got a bunch of non-political
stuff
we got i want to talk about the falcon
in the winter soldier because i've been
watching that show and everyone thinks
it's getting woke and i think it's
getting anti-woke but we'll see what
happens
so hanging out today i guess just two
members of the dc ride squad
which one you you fight over who goes
first mr richard mcginnis oh why thank
you
thank you so much you guys talking to
the microphone richie uh richie mcginnis
uh yep the dc riot squad slash daily
caller video squad
at richie mcginnis and uh at daily
caller with my boy jorge
jorge over here yeah you know phil's
correspondent uh daily caller
and yeah you know i guess we uh
originated with the
you know dc riot squad so glad to be
back and
you know for an exciting week both of
you guys were on the ground during the
riots
yep that's true both you guys have been
on the ground for basically every single
ride over the past year
well not literally everyone because
there's like multiple cities the same
time but most of the big consequential
ones like notably kenosha
and so what's important here and i think
it's gonna be great because not only
were you guys in the minnesota you guys
were in minnesota
yeah not only is that relevant for all
the news but there was
uh some legal analyst speculating that
the riots
are going to have a ramification on the
kyle rittenhouse trial because
they're telling the jury do what we want
or we burn this place down
and so you know one legal analyst said
what do you think is going to happen
when it comes to the jury in the
rittenhouse trial they know what they're
going to be there for they're going to
be like no way dude
am i getting involved in this so we're
going to talk all about that we also got
ian he's chilling ian crossland at ian
cross on richard
jorge oh good to see you brother how do
you feel about it how do you feel about
being called richard is that yours
that's my what my mom calls me when i'm
in trouble
she still says it like when i go to
minneapolis and i'm like i'm in
minneapolis mom
sorry mom there's a bunch of gunshots
going off richard
i told her day of when i went to kenosha
hey by the way i'm in wisconsin
and she said all caps don't be a hero
did she ask you to get like a big life
insurance policy because you're taking
no for real like work conflict reporters
usually get big life insurance policies
because like
dude come on like they're shooting each
other out there do you ever guys just
straight up rich
only or dick i'm i'm only hoping i'm
hoping to be rich in name
i like where your head's at because of
dogecoin oh yeah
we're not gonna go there don't get them
started
all right all right we got lydia just
pressing all the buttons i'm in the
corner i am the least interesting person
on this podcast tonight it's gonna be a
great night i'm looking forward to
what's going on in minneapolis thanks
guys
everybody before we get started go to
timcast.com and become a member and
guess what we put up the first episode
of the blog
after like eight months of talking about
it and
you know we just we're gonna start it
off we're gonna figure it out as we go
but we have to just start doing it
otherwise it never gets done so we got
this episode up we got this pro
guy mike feedy he did a grind on the
grind bar was fantastic go to
timecast.com you'll see all the stuff
but become a member
because we have this massive library of
members only exclusive content and
tonight
after this show there will be an
exclusive members only segment again for
all of you who sign up and don't forget
to like share subscribe hit that
notification bell and i also want to
announce
real quick i believe today
maybe tomorrow will be the last day you
can get your tinfoil gorilla t-shirt
i let it go a little bit longer because
people were mentioning that payday comes
you like once every other week for
a lot of people and they have a chance
to get paid they want to buy the shirt
so you'll notice
if you go to timcast.com click store
there is an i'm a gorilla shirt he's
wearing a tinfoil hat
we'll keep that up from maybe another
day or so but again a lot of people have
mentioned like you know
bi-weekly like you know ever like a
paycheck every other week so we might
keep it up at least for a few more days
but it's going to be going away very
soon
because it was meant to just be a
limited edition thing it's already been
for a long time so uh that there you go
again like whatever oh and if you're
listening on itunes and spotify leave us
a good review because give us five stars
because it helps us out all right okay
let's get to the news
we got the story from dailymail.com.uk
maxine waters
may have handed defense grounds for
appeal
and the turning over of this trial derek
chauvin trial judge blasts a poor
democrat for calling for riots if no
conviction
they say derek chopin's defense attorney
eric nelson called for a mistrial
after the jury retired on monday he
cited rep maxine waters comments on the
case
as he argued there was no way the jury
could be unbiased given constant media
coverage he's right
now that we have u.s representatives
threatening acts of violence and
retaliation to this trial it's frankly
mind-blowing nelson said
judge peter cahill replied i grant you
congresswoman waters may have handed you
grounds for appeal
and the turning over of this trial but
cahill refused to grant a mistrial
and adjourned the court until the jury
comes back with a verdict it wasn't just
that
the defense argued prosecutorial
misconduct
because in rebuttal the prosecution said
that i guess they were like making their
they were telling stories
and it was nonsense and repeatedly kept
saying
that it was essentially fabrication of
facts which you're not allowed to do
in court the prosecution's supposed to
say that you know our expert testified
to this and we hold this to be correct
you can't say the other person's making
making up crap and they're lying and
telling stories
and so when the defense said you know
objection the judge said overruled
don't say stories again but you know
he's allowed to say stories that when
the prosecution kept berating the
defense and insulting them the judge
finally stepped down like okay you got
to stop doing that
this is what bugs me we just saw how
long were the riots going on this so far
in minneapolis
you guys look they've been uh since were
the recent ones since
last sunday the death of dante wright so
about about eight days yeah a week
nelson immediately the defense for for
chauvin asked the judge to sequester the
jury
and he said so they don't watch the news
they don't see what's going on and the
judge said well
i'll instruct the jury not to watch the
news and the defense argued
everyone knows about what's going on
everyone's talking about it
and he was saying that even tv shows
fictional tv shows on thursday night nbc
or whatever
are referencing the trial and making
statements about what they want to occur
and so he's like you need to sequester
then the judge initially said no then
after the riots started with dante right
then he was like judge i'd like to ask
you again it's a question to the jury
that just like i don't think we need to
do that
and now the judge is like well the jury
the trial may be completely overturned
that's incompetent what does that mean
overturn is that a mistrial so
it means there'll be a verdict then the
defense is
let's say that the jurors come back and
say guilty on all counts
i mean let's say the jury comes back and
says acquitted on all counts but
manslaughter
no matter what happens now the defense
can file an appeal to a higher court
saying
rhett maxine waters democrat came
from california came to our state and
said unless we get
a conviction for premeditated murder
which they didn't charge chauvin with
we're going to get more confrontational
they've already been rioting what does
more confrontational mean
yamiche is that her name yeah
yamiche alcindor said the right is
claiming that
maxine waters called for violence
because she said get more active and
more confrontational
that's not a call for violence and i'm
like
confrontational what does that mean like
confronting somebody
if you're already burning down their
buildings and throwing bricks at cops
what is more confrontational than that
now the judge is admitting yep there it
is the jury the jury of course knows
they've been threatened and they're
going to burn the city down no matter
what because she said first degree
murder and they don't have that
yeah they don't and then and i thought
at minimum they would at least sequester
before the
the weekend started they didn't even
even do that and that's obviously when
when maxine waters
came in i mean i think just being on the
ground um one of our reporters lisa
bennett
she did a great video where she asked
folks hey you know what happens if you
don't get
you know if you guys don't get murdered
and people literally say and that are
from brooklyn center said we're burning
it down we're burning down
everybody and they don't need um i would
say uh
you know with maxine waters comments
it's like just you're just giving these
people
more power to just say hey if we do this
we're good to go and i think a lot of
those folks are going to point to last
time and say hey we go out and
you know do our thing it's okay because
kamala harris was there to bail us out
just like last year
and i think that's something that we
have to keep up back in our mind
i think all the cops should resign i
think every single cop in
in the minneapolis area should just
resign right now
just get out of there just leave oh
that's tough
they voted for it that they did um and i
know right now
the the big difference right now is
compared to last year is um
you know being on the ground is i guess
minnesota with the law enforcements they
didn't have a communication system
between
you know the minnesota state troopers
national guard and then local police so
coming this this year around
being on the ground reporting we learned
that now minnesota has created a program
called
operation safety net so now we have the
national guard local police and state
troopers now working all basically now
hand in hand
to control these groups i will say this
i think you know richard you know being
on the ground again in brooklyn center
they did a great job of protecting the
police department you know they put the
barricades they had the law enforcement
there
but one thing that we we have to
remember and i try to tell these folks
all the time is
when you have so much law enforcement
you know concentrate on just one area
it leaves the rest of the city stretched
in i mean just and and i i said this
last uh this was
reported yesterday but numbers might
even be higher but since last sunday of
dante wright's death
the police department in brooklyn center
which is a little small town area they
have
already received over 200 calls of
either businesses damaged
looted or burglaries and that's one
thing that we have to remember is when
you have so much protection at the
police center
the rest of the city that whole shopping
mall is literally right next to the
police station like
that whole shopping mall that was looted
on the first couple of nights it's
like a hundred yards from this whole
police station this is why i'm saying
the cops should resign
or or the very least you know we had uh
i think it was tom rogan he mentioned
they should give notice that in 30 days
they'll all resign that'd be interesting
i've been speaking to some inside
sources
inside the portland pd from last summer
and when i was speaking to a police
officer she said the morale
is low she says we have people
transferring you know you know just
don't say retir yeah return retiring
early
and i mean i i would expect that we see
the same thing here and i know that um
we were speaking about this before the
show tim but the minnesota uh senate
just approved
nine million dollars to get out of state
law enforcement
to to help out you know with this
upcoming week so
you know pray for these guys because
yeah they they take a lot of beating
when they're out there
there are lot i i i've heard from a lot
of people in the comments they're like
tim these cops who are staying are doing
it because they know there are good
people who need to be protected
you know the way i described it was your
house is on fire we repeatedly tried
we tried fighting the fire last year but
a bunch of people in the house voted for
the arsonists
kamala harris was bailing these people
out soliciting funds joe biden whose
staff is funding the bailouts
and i'm like so at that point it made
sense to be like stay and fight
figuratively have you know show people
what this means and then vote for
somebody who will defend you
and they went democrat they voted for
the people who are for defending the
rioters not the cops
so now you got a problem now your house
is burning down and the people you think
you're helping are screaming at you to
get out while the house burns down
around them so i understand the analogy
words like we got to help the people
here who are good and i'm like
i get that but at a certain point don't
you say like the people like imagine a
firefighter goes in a burning house and
he's like i'm gonna get you out of here
ma'am and then she like just grabs on
and squeezes a flaming beam as high as
you can like no i'm staying
the firefighter's gotta get out before
he gets you know engulfed in the flames
uh look the people who are there who are
good people
what are they doing to defend these cops
do we see press conferences held by
community leaders and activists and
neighborhood watchers saying
we support our cops and we need them
here to protect us no but what do we see
we see endless riots in support of
shutting down and abolishing the police
so so at a certain point the police need
to send a message
if you're not getting the support nobody
wants you there they voted for the
people who hate you
then you need to say okay then i'll pass
it off to you and then see what happens
you know the metaphor i'm thinking of is
that 10 guilty people go free before one
innocent person suffers
and i think that these people that
aren't speaking up are the innocent
bystanders that i don't want them to
suffer that's that's a different analogy
but it doesn't work i'm not sure if
you've seen the news too is one of the
city council members from brooklyn
center came out and said hey you know
i get the emotions of heart but we
should wait for due process got fart
so that was the city manager yep and
then a council woman for brooklyn center
admitted
she voted to have him fired because she
was scared they would come after her
all right personal responsibility takes
precedent at a certain point if you
would fire a city manager who called for
due process
because you know this cop shot this guy
and then publicly say i'm scared they'll
attack me
okay you need to either stand up for
what you believe in
or don't come to me for help when you
when you vote to
support these lunatics look at a certain
point you got to throw water on the fire
too but what i think it is tim from from
being on the ground because
and i think richard attested this is we
spoke to a lot of residents who don't
support
obviously the constant clashes in their
neighborhood the destruction the only
thing is
they're they're actually afraid just to
even go on camera without interviewing
because they feel like
if i go on camera with you they'll
destroy myself tomorrow
i think there is a lot of community
people that do want to stand up they
want to speak out
i think they're just super afraid of the
retaliation exactly because if they feel
like the media the culture
everyone is since trump since trump left
i mean
very much like during you know the last
year
a lot of the riots have been like us
versus the federal government a la
donald trump no trump no kkk no racist
usa but now that biden's president
it's the system itself and so you're
right
like the protesters on the ground i
think the ideology has shifted even
even further left because basically now
it's like okay now you really adopt our
plan or else you're a fascist as well so
biden's a fascist
if you know he doesn't adopt abolish the
police in fact look i i get messages
from people all the time where they're
like
i got my family out of minnesota last
week or i'm moving next month or
i'm trying to move out now i get
messages from people say i moved out six
months ago
i got i've got messages from people
where they were like man tim i'm glad
you you said to get out of the city
because i got up before the latest riot
started and i lived real close
so listen i i hear what you're saying by
people scared to go on camera
the founding fathers many of them who
signed the declaration of independence
were killed had their homes burned down
their families were killed they risked
everything to stand up what they
believed in
at a certain point you don't get to be a
pampered golden age american who can sit
in your home and just kick your feet
back and say i'll keep my head down and
be fine
because they are it is expanding it is
getting worse there are a lot of pundits
saying they think the riots after the
chauvin trial gonna be worse than we saw
last year
it's one thing to see the anger over the
death of george floyd
it's another thing to see the state say
he didn't do anything wrong depending on
what the result may be
so maxine waters wants a charge that
didn't actually happen
first degree murder premeditation so
based on her own logic riots are coming
if at this point the people are
unwilling to stand up and defend
themselves
okay well do you expect the like the the
people who are
who are who are speaking up not even
from your area
who are speaking out and risking their
careers who are getting canceled losing
their jobs for defending
you know the the what's what's true and
what's correct
you expect them to come to your aid when
you won't do it yourself
there's that famous line about a leader
who says i would never instruct one of
my men to do something i wouldn't do
myself or one of my you know
men or women yet here you have people
who won't stand up for themselves asking
you to do it for them
and so their cops were like i will i'm
like nah at a certain point
if you're a cop and they're all turning
their back on you refusing to stand up
and even say the words i support you
then you don't have support from them no
matter what they think no matter what
they're telling people
they're lying somebody who truly
supported you would stand up
hold the press conference we support the
police and we reject this
they won't do it why because they're
scared of the extremists
and they aren't willing to fight back in
a figurative sense in any capacity
so at a certain point the cops got to be
like then you're on your own
because what happens kim potter a
26-year veteran
there's a guy wanted for aggravated
robbery dante right
he's resisting arrest he's wanted on a
gun charge so they know he's likely
armed i believe he had a 45 ruger
jumps into his car and she doesn't know
what he's what's going on
and she draws her weapon presumably the
story is she thought it was her taser
she shoots him
this is a tragedy but when you have a
guy wanted for an aggravated robber it's
like robertson with a deadly weapon
and then he jumps in his car you're like
okay
he's he's resisted and he may he's act
it's active aggression
should she then defend herself or defend
others
well she says she made a mistake for
that the prosecutor comes out when he
came out during the riots i guess and
said
we are going to do everything in our
power to see her
held accountable through this system
okay she deserves it
she absolutely deserves whatever the
system throws at her because all of
these cops have been watching
what the feckless pathetic spineless
people of their community have been
doing
selling them out sacrificing them to the
mob
and they thought they'd be safe they
thought the mob would ignore them
they thought they could stand there as a
part of the system propping up
injustice and they would be safe nah not
anymore
you you helped prop up a bunch of
arsonists burning down your community
and now you're mad that you're caught in
the fire i'm not i can't run into a
burning building you chose to be
i don't like this metaphor because the
people of the united states are sucking
off the teat of the federal reserve
bankrupting the world and we don't
deserve to die and be
burned and healthy foreign you're
punishing people for something they're
not necessarily responsible for or we're
ignorant of the federal reserve has
nothing to do with it it's the people of
the united states
are spearheading the global catastrophe
financially
you got to get back on subject you're
talking about the people of the city
being responsible because they're not
saying anything no because they voted
for
harris some of them but not all of them
the majority of the state voted for the
people who support the riots and they
still
but there's they won't speak there's a
huge number of people that didn't and
even
and they don't deserve to do silence
well is that the no no no no are they
the reason i think they said they're not
is because they're not organized and if
one of them sticks their head up it is
gonna get they
won't even say the words i don't know
man they won't speak up to save their
own lives
then you get no sympathy from me you
have the option to simply stand up and
say
hello good journalist jorge i wish the
police had more support they won't even
do that they're scared well i'm sorry
man
life is not always candy canes and
rainbows and when
violent terrorists come to burn down
your neighborhood you at least have to
say please stop
at the at the bare minimum say officer
please help us they won't even do that
so if you've got terrorists burning down
your city and you don't have the ability
to at least say
help sorry yeah but like jorge was
saying if they get on camera and they
say help
their business is going to get destroyed
the next all that is required for evil
to succeed is that good people do
nothing yeah but
or good people put themselves out there
vulnerably that also helps evil succeed
how does that make it because they get
killed easy people need to stand up and
at least do something instead of nothing
you're saying they gotta organize they
might risk themselves well it starts by
speaking
well but not not randomly and
incoherently who's that who said
anything about random
income not like one random person to get
up and be like i'm gonna make i'm gonna
be the guy that makes a stand and gets
my birth
if they if they formed underground like
the founding
as a metaphor your argument is absurd no
they they organized they weren't just
like players who fund the police
the founding fathers didn't get up and
say king george
i hereby declare you're an idiot because
they would have been executed on the
spot
no they had to organize underground for
for maybe a certain period but they
literally had constitutional conventions
in their states and sent delegates
yeah and they voted on these things
right but it was all under these people
are paying for the police
they're paying for the government
they're paying the politicians and
voting for them
and i'll tell you this the people who
voted for it why would i argue they
don't want it
if somebody was in minneapolis and said
i want joe biden whose staff members
support the rights and i want kamala
harris who supports the rioters
and then the writers come to burn down
their house i can only assume they're
going yes
i voted for this i'm happy it's
happening why would you assume they made
that mistake i don't know what was in
there was in their mind
it's like that guy in los angeles when
the riots were in downtown l.a or
whatever and he was cheering this is
awesome yeah burn it down
and then when they came with him without
a block of his house he goes no stop
don't come to my house
do you think it's that or do you think
people were misled by the portrayal of
what was been going what what has been
going on for this
year perhaps if they knew you know the
full extent of
what has been happening personal
responsibility too many americans for
too long have been fat and lazy
figuratively and literally sitting
around not paying attention thinking
everything would be done for them
and i'll put it this way firefighters
risking their lives
because the da's won't prosecute these
people you want to get mad at cops okay
why should a firefighter risk his life
running into literal burning buildings
that are collapsing
because when the police make arrests the
d.a cuts them loose
you want to support your community you
need to speak up and do it but if people
are sitting back saying someone will do
it for me
eventually your house falls down because
you're not maintaining it i cannot
you guys cannot and the police cannot be
the people who are
begging just carry your own weight dude
for once
they won't do it they won't so they vote
for it
and it's i'll tell you this ignorance is
no excuse for supporting
tyranny i i understand the media
manipulates i hate him for it
i understand that these these extremists
are terrorizing and threatening them
but if you don't stand up and just at
least
try and no one does this is here anyway
this is the
why i brought up the federal reserve and
the u.s people ignorance is no excuse
for supporting tyranny
we live in the empire so being ignorant
of that
is not an excuse to support that that's
correct that's my point you're right but
i don't want to punish and destroy
everyone you know who's
who's you you mean you wouldn't join
anti-fuzz what you're saying well i just
i i have this stupid sympathy for those
ignorant
people i don't want to see them suffer
no one does well you're making the
argument that you want the police to
leave so
i'm sorry richie what what breeds that
ignorance like why aren't people aware
of that we live in a medium society
we for too long have been people in good
times
breeding weak individuals weak citizens
who don't care about civic duty or
responsibility
and i'm not talking about some
nationalistic whatever i'm talking about
literally being like
going and giving your firefighters some
brownies and being like thank you for
everything you do or going to your cops
and talking to them about issues you're
concerned about you've heard about the
media they don't even do that
they don't even they don't even do that
it's just media manipulation
political sectarianism and a bunch of
lazy disinterested people who are like
i'm keeping my head down cause i got it
good okay listen
there was a period in in our sis in our
in our country in our nation's history
where death was like
god you died you know i mean look at
these stories from back in like the old
pioneer days in the wild west people
understood risk
and responsibility and they had to wake
up at six in the morning and farm and go
to bed at 11 at night and it was work
work work all day every day
now we have all of the comforts of the
first world we have fast food mcdonald's
we get
we we have too much food americans are
gaining weight like crazy and they're
doing less work and there
now you have a whole section of a sect
of people who are leftist who think they
shouldn't have to do work at all
we are just becoming as a country
we we reject responsibility for our own
lives and our own selves and we say the
police will do it
and then when the police can't do it
they're overrun well i'm not going to
speak up someone else have to do it
okay well then listen man if a fire is
raging towards your home and you're like
i'm not gonna put out a firefight i'll
get here
okay well eventually your house burns
down that's not me saying i want your
husband i don't want your house to burn
down
but it's also me saying i don't want my
firefighters to die because you refused
to start
turn your hose on the very least you
could have done that right
and and and wet your house down now your
house is a raging five alarm fire and
the firefighters one's gonna die because
of you
that's why i'm saying the police need to
back out before things
but before look i'll tell you what's
gonna happen the cops stick around
we get a kim potter situation if the
cops right off the bat said we won't
stand for this
well then kim potter wouldn't have been
there to create another circumstance
that they use to light the country on
fire
i'm not saying i know the solution is
but i can tell you this it's a chinese
finger trap and the cops keep pulling
and you're not going to get out of it
keep doing this
the people around you won't support you
so something needs to change and it's
changed now so people realize what's
happening
even when the cops are there i mean
kenosha there were no firefighters and
no cops like in the situation where they
were actually needed like a shooting or
a fire you know we saw they were
basically focused like jorge was saying
earlier
entirely on the riots and so like over
the last year if you look all
at all the criminal data across the
country i mean that's effectively what's
been happening is the police are paying
attention to these
the civil unrest and and not paying
attention to the violent crimes that
actually really impact the communities
yeah well one thing too is it is
interesting that i think we'll we'll
start to figure out these couple months
is how each
city major city deals with the potential
civil unrest
and and the communication they've used i
um in los angeles the los angeles county
sheriff alex
van noyva he came out aggressive and
said hey we got national guard on
standby
we got all this and stuff we are not
playing around compared last year
and according to some sources on the
ground i mean lapd so far as i know this
past week has been
handling the demonstrations pretty well
and i think i think los angeles i mean i
don't know about every city but
no los angeles has they they for sure
are going to fix the mistakes they made
last year because
they're they're kind of sheriff is a
little bit aggressive but uh i i do
definitely see what tim is saying
they need the police officers are law
enforcement they need some type of
support
it needs to come from somewhere in
portland uh i speak to a lot of officers
they feel like their work is useless
because they'll make the arrest they'll
do all this stuff but then the district
attorney will say
off the hook off the hook off the hook
and that's going to bring morale down
and i think in los angeles what we're
seeing is we're seeing an l.a county
sheriff say hey we're taking the
aggressive lane
we're ready to go we have national guard
on standby and and i know they
the the d.a down there george cascone is
not uh it's not a guy they like he's
super progressive but
even the l.a county sheriff is saying we
don't even care what the da's doing
we're going
bullhead you know all forces in and um
so far
la hasn't seen uh that that violence
that we've seen in in other cities
what's the internet's definition of
insanity doing the same thing over and
over again expecting a different outcome
that's einstein yeah was it i'd say i
think it was a meme so you got these
cops in portland who are like i'm gonna
arrest this guy for breaking the law
and then they bring him to station and
the d.a goes you're free to go and they
go hey
i know i'll arrest him tomorrow for
breaking the law and the diego is you're
free to go
the woman who who set fi was accused of
setting fire to the police union
building
she was arrested last year on some
serious charges and they just cut her
loose drop the charges
then she comes back not even a year
later and burns down the police union
building
and then they release her without bail
at a certain point man
i don't i don't know what these cops
think they're doing it's like there's
this meme video where a guy
what else can they do though you know
please i mean but you got
built they got bills to pay you know
that's not realistic for somebody who
your house is burning down will you be
like i can't leave i'm homeless i'll be
homeless
but it's like my house is burning down
but my family's gonna starve if
we don't stay so you stay in a house
that's literally on fire you're
still getting a paycheck you know as
long as you're alive as long as what you
just said is very interesting
what you've said is it's actually safer
and easier for the police
to be in the violent riots in a system
that's broken not working than it is to
actually leave and go somewhere
somewhere that would be more because
what what is a cop's future employment
in this current climate right now oh hey
i just left the portland pd
uh you want to hire me to be an nbc
correspondent no no think about that
think about that that means
while minneapolis burns down it is
actually safer and more secure for an
officer
to be an ineffective and villainized
individual working for the department
than it is for them to move their family
to any other city for any other job
if a small portion of my garage caught
on fire i wouldn't expect everyone to
run screaming from the building i'd
expect someone to go with the fire
station which
put a little fire out if the fire
eventually engulfed half the building
then this the safety is okay at this
point you stay in the building you're
probably gonna die you need to get out
yeah the fire right now isn't big enough
to where the cops feel threatened
and i think well i think basically the
fire here you know the responsibility of
the fourth estate is literally
to call out when there's a fire when
nobody else is willing to like the
government
you know obviously isn't worth the state
you say yeah well so
i mean you guys i mean well i mean
basically mainstream media
well i think we have the internet now
and i do think
when we started out covering the riots
at the beginning of the year we were
saying
pro the term protesters um not calling
them rioters necessarily let me let me
pause real quick
i'll pull this story up as a good
launching point yeah for sure we got the
story from willamette week
marchers set fire to apple store and
shatter windows across downtown portland
after police killing
the scale of damage tonight recalled the
riots last may
here's what i love about this article
they say it's a riot last may
but right now they are marchers the
media is absolutely shielding these
people but uh you know
that's for sure well i think i was
trying to make the point kind of from
the other side which is
it's it's just as bad to then come out
there and and label every single person
who's out there
in a situation where you know police
start banging up against the front line
of protesters they declare unlawful
assembly
some of those people were out there with
good intentions so if you say blm
terrorists in every single tweet then
basically you're throwing yourself into
that trench the other trench and so
you need people in the middle who are
just trying their their best to look at
both and say like
okay so we use the term protester
because it's like same as the capital
riot
there were certain people there who were
caught up in the madness the lord of the
flies effects of the chaos
you start getting pepper sprayed it's
pretty hard to make logical decisions
they didn't like so using that neutral
terminology wasn't good in the short
term i was like oh you're not going to
get as many retweets
but in the long term people started to
pay attention because they're like oh
these guys are actually here and they're
actually trying their best to actually
just show
fly on the wall what's going on how many
people are actively have you heard
actively call for the cops to resign or
leave
i mean that's that's a good point though
probably only me right yeah because my
position is i understand not everyone
out there is a violent terrorist
but there are many violent terrorists i
understand a lot of people go out there
and they're peaceful protesters
the problem with the leftist activists
is that they they
espouse a support for what's called
diversity of tactics
have you heard this phrase from the from
from antifa yeah
diversity of tactics basically means
that if you're a peaceful protester you
are supposed to
defend yeah or at the very least
tolerate violent extremists who are
burning things down and attacking police
respect the diversity of tactics it's an
excuse they have they have
systems where they need bodies you're
right they exploit that that's for sure
so but but so there are regular peaceful
protesters who go out there knowing this
and then say but i had good intentions
even though i dressed in all black to
shield the extremists now what they say
about the police is
if if you have what do they say if you
have 1300
good cops and 12 of them are bad then
and and the 1300 good cops won't call
out the 12 bad cops
then you have 1 312 you know
bad cops i think that's right one three
one two hey cab and so
the point in the left is making is the
same the cops who refuse to speak out
and stop the bad cops are just as bad so
i look at that and i'm like there's no
liter there's no legit solution between
two warring ideologies
convincing this that is evil but there
is one simple solution
if the people of these neighborhoods
won't defend the police
that means the police don't have their
support and if the
the people and the other people in these
communities be it maybe a smaller
percentage
are actively voting against the police
yeah and the police
have a very simple answer instead of
arguing about who's evil and who's not
you leave you don't got to worry about
support you don't got to worry about the
violence
and you don't got to worry about they
asked for it they get it
everyone everyone's better off so my
only point is you're a commentator right
so
your call for the police to do this or
that
that's legitimate our role here is to be
on the ground
and to say what we're seeing right and
so when you have
the entire media whose responsibility is
to be on the ground and say what they're
seeing and they're either
trying to portray this in this light or
this in that light i got my ass beat by
cops in wauwatosa
with a billy club and i showed the
freaking bruise on my knee and
everyone's like oh the bootlicker
finally
it's like no no how many times have i
shown you know the
the blm snack van getting the windows
smashed in dc
by this white shirt cop who just decided
to smash a freaking window we're not
like choosing oh no the cops are good so
we're not gonna post that one
it's like right that's but that's the
way that this should have been covered
from the start and the reason why we're
in this situation now
is because nobody was paying attention
to us because it was two different echo
chambers and after time
maybe some people are but still you know
it's
very much two different trenches right i
should i should qualify my previous
statement
when i said calling for police to resign
obviously the left is doing nothing but
that
yeah my reasoning is very very different
yeah yeah yeah because they're being
sacrificed and disrespected and the
people in the community won't do
anything to stand up for themselves so
clarification yeah i understood but yeah
so you get
that's why i pulled up the willamette
weak thing marchers
set fire to an apple store they torched
that place it was gutted
and they're not marchers they're you
know what
i think calling the people who did that
rioters is being generous
yeah because they're political
motivation they're seeing anarchists
then
no a terrorist austere marchers
well um austere local activists well
while me and rich were on the ground in
in brooklyn center
um i caught i got i caught a few
interesting kind of moments on video
where
you'll find black locals from brooklyn
center
yelling at white you could call them
protesters or agitators and tell them
we don't want violence in our
neighborhoods we don't condone this
and they and then tell them hey when
that that 10 p.m curfew hits
we all want to go home because i think
one one thing that maybe a lot of folks
don't know unless you're on the ground
and i try to
i try to put it out much as out there as
i can is what makes this situation for
brooklyn center police department
um difficult to control this crowd is
because right across the street
you have all these apartment complexes
so you have kids in these buildings so
that's one thing that we try to put out
is a lot of the the black locals in
brooklyn center literally came out
and we're telling the white protesters
hey don't be burning down our city don't
be doing this to our neighborhoods
we literally have kids here we have to
be here um until tomorrow so i think
that was
an interesting thing that uh i was kind
of able to capture we wanted to wanted
to put it out there or the guy's name
they have they all have fighters and it
was pretty funny to see the minnesota
freedom fighters predominantly black all
go up to
the antifa um which i've been referring
to as the umbrella gang because you know
they're basically like rolling around
with their umbrellas completely in
formation the whole time
they're bringing like wooden barriers up
to the fence and stuff and the guys are
like
what are you doing yeah like we're out
here to protest
it's not to like smash with police like
we're trying to get our voice out here
what is your goal you know and then one
thing too tim is then the one the white
protesters of the antifa will then
uh basically claim that the that the
black men of uh the black minnesota
freedom fighters
are uh uh working with the police and
they're getting paid under the table so
it was interesting to just hear that go
down in person
it's because you look at the data
peaceful protests work
it generates press coverage which
generates sympathy and then makes
political change
it works and violent riots do the
opposite like we saw
with the the civics poll after george
floyd's death
net net support for black lives matter
reached like 27 percent
and then after the riots it dropped
lower than it had been the year before
people don't like rising i wish people
would realize that the best place to
peacefully protest is on the internet
on video in the 60s it was you got a
huge crowd so that hopefully you get
some media attention so people will come
with a camera and put you on tv on abc
news
you don't need that anymore now you make
a youtube video with 70 000 views
you change 20 000 minds and then
political change happens well
i i think a good example though is
twitter activists took over twitter and
use it to ban
people and destroy the careers of those
they oppose it it was fully protesting i
mean i
you know just from an outsider
perspective i mean it could have been
even more powerful
like let's say when this george floyd
thing happened for them to say hey you
know what
let's get a million man march in
washington dc
we're going to go up and we're going to
demand these bills and we're going to do
it peacefully and
you know i think that would have been
more powerful and instead of the rights
because when the riots happen then you
know me and richard been on the ground
uh one thing that we try to do at the
daily caller i think um you know not
much folks did is
after the riots we would at least spend
a couple days like actually talking to
the business owners
and a lot of them say hey we supported
this movement from like day one
and now we're just we just don't
understand why and you just turn off a
lot of
america when you go that problem i mean
like i said i think outside of
perspective pyruvate would have been
more powerful to say hey let's get a
million people let's show up in
washington d.c
let's march peacefully and and you know
let's demand a set of bills and i think
right now too with black lives matter nt
for whoever you want to
uh categorize these groups is they don't
have a list of demands that's like a
legit like hey we're going off this
because you know when you speak to one
person once person says
abolish the whole system then some
people say oh we want some police we
want community police it's a
mixed message i don't believe i don't i
don't believe what the businesses to be
honest
when i i've you guys have been to
berkeley i'd imagine right no yeah
so in you you go to you go to oakland
you go to berkeley go to the bay area
and all the businesses have these pro
leftist signs in their windows
one of them actually said i remember it
was a burger king and it said this is a
family owned
you know franchise please do not destroy
our windows see that they had to say it
outright because it was a burger king
you know the local brewery just puts
whatever leftist trash in their window
hoping that it
spares them so when you get it when you
get a journalist who comes out because
i've
i've i've talked to people on the record
off the record i'll tell you this on the
record they're like we're big supporters
of the movement
just you know we're hoping that they
they don't destroy our business you turn
the camera off and they're like i can't
stand any of this what are they doing i
hate it
but they want to say it publicly because
they're trying to beg
they're begging extremists and i'll tell
you what happens this is the product of
apathy and politics the district
attorneys who get elected
are funded by leftist progressives
who will not prosecute their own so the
cops arrest them they get cut loose and
then they burn they set fire to the
police union building
then local businesses are forced to just
bend the knee because they have nothing
no justice system left to defend them
at what point is it a crime for a da to
release a criminal
i don't think i don't think it is i mean
like in los angeles right now they just
elected george cascone and he's been one
of the more progressive da's
and like like i'm saying the l.a county
sheriff and him are just butting heads
on everything
i've actually spoken to a few police
officers uh and lapd on the record and
off the record who tell me like hey
some of the people that we arrest we
charge them for rape within like a
couple days
out on the street and they'll like
commit a murder so
that's it's just um you know i mean at
one point two you have to ask is like
you know what
at one point is it a crime because it's
like you're putting your own community
in danger and the people that you say
that you're protecting which is always
black and brown we want to protect the
black and brown communities that's what
you're actually impacting the most when
you do this is the black and brown
communities
it's like they're not gonna they're not
these criminals are not getting released
in beverly hills i'll tell you that
no if they get arrested beverly hills
they'll get shipped somewhere else
but you know who you know who seems to
have learned to give up because of
politics these da's they're like
whatever man
nobody actually cares about their
community anymore so i'll tell them what
they want to hear and then just do
nothing
and then all the cast happens like the
cops haven't learned yet
they're like i'm gonna keep doing the
same thing over and over again even
though nothing's getting resolved
but i guess hey when you're getting a
paycheck and you got a house you got a
mortgage payment
i suppose from my perspective
you know i said this two three years ago
the escalation
i said i said this i think two years ago
that we were going to see
heavily racialized riots or riots for
racial reasons escalate because of a lot
of critical race
and tim i wanted to bring this up too
because i know when we talk about this
stuff it's you know um
riots and stuff but i think one thing
too we maybe need to look at as a
society and i think maybe the adam
toledo
was a great ex not a great example but
something that we could look at as
america is
you know what about the family structure
you know i think one thing that we're
not talking about
is is a lot of these people who are
causing the riots or out there you know
um taking advantage of of any civil
unrest um
what kind what type of family were they
raised did they have both parents at
home and i think that's another
discussion that america needs to start
um having you know i know with adam
toledo
yeah yeah but hold on to address that
point you realize a lot of these black
lives matter people are white
progressives
from middle class families or upper
middle class families i think there was
a
but just because they're from upper
middle class family doesn't mean their
dad was in a [ __ ] bag
no i mean but their dad could be a lazy
middle-class uh intellectual is that the
right
yeah he could be a huge wall street guy
could be a huge wall street guy who made
them millions of dollars you know and
he's rich as heck but his daddy
was never there and he's so mad about it
it's a good point but i want to make
sure we're clarifying that
it's not necessarily about whether you
got mom or dad it's about are your
parents
lazy and apathetic you could have two
parents
and they can just like they won't smack
you around when you're no no
i mean like they send you they send you
to school and then when you're begging
for help and attention they put you on
drugs
yeah and then you grow up messed up
because you never had any real
leadership in your family i think we're
saying the same way
you're drunk i'm not but you like smack
him around like no no
no you know come on i mean i turned out
just fine all right come on
i imagine it's easy for a dad to just
drink a drink a few beers at night
rather than look as kid in the eyes
unfortunately
yeah we need a dad who's got like you
know he's doing like you know kung fu
and his
his five-year-old son is doing a little
kung fu next to him there's a video
i watched it was amazing it was this
dude and his like nephew i guess
and he's doing uh like some kind of
gymnastics training
and the little kid is imitating him and
then dude who's like probably 30 and
super rip does a backflip and the little
kid does a backflip
and the guy lands and looks looks at
this kid he's like
dude kid just did it because kids want
to learn from you so maybe yeah family
structure is is correct i just wanted to
clarify
i think i think we need to bring that
conversation up with american politics
because
that's not talked about enough um i
think having the two-parent system
uh in the home i think all these things
did you just say
did you assume the gender of those
parents
[Laughter]
no sorry about that but i you know i
think i was like reading something yeah
mark's that time like don't cancel jorge
but i mean i think like i said it's an
interesting thing to look at because i
remember
when i was covering the uh you know
riots in every different city but
specifically in portland i that's one
thing that i kind of caught myself is
is you know when everyone's causing
destruction is to say you know how many
of these people who are out here
um grow up with with just a regular
family and
and and have a sense of purpose in life
because many of the people that i talk
to they
almost have like no no sense of purpose
and when this george floyd thing caught
you know popped out they finally felt
they were part of a movement and they're
they were making a change
i don't know that's what i think it's
been i think it's their dad's i think
it's mostly
the dad yeah you know no i agree so it's
not so a lot of people like to mention
whether
you know people have dads or don't i
don't think that six we we brushed on
this i think literally
yeah if you don't have a dad you the
studies show
that there's going to be actually i'm
sorry i should clarify that actually the
studies have been simplified to just two
parents
a two-parent structure but i think if
people don't have a discipline like a
disciplinary parent and i don't mean by
like corporal punishment i mean
literally like
sit down son and you know met or sit
down you know daughter and
you know think about what you did and
you need a a
leadership role and a nurturing role in
my opinion i think there's probably a
lot of these these kids i mean you look
at these auntie kids
it's like they've never left like
they've never picked up a heavy backpack
in their lives they're so scrawny and
frail
but they're angry they're really angry
and purposeless
so i i will say i don't think they
actually believe in anything
i really don't know some don't like i
said some the
some that i talked to in portland they
finally felt like
like this was their calling they were
they're part of a movie that they were
gonna make a change
but what what what's what's their
supposed goal police brutality
let me let me pull up this next story we
got this one from fox news
black lives matter protesters rally for
a victim leave after learning he was
white
the original story reported was that
they left when they learned he was a
carjacker i read that and i was like
hold on a minute
the the dante right dude he was a wanted
for aggravated robbery
the crime committed is not the reason
they're supporting or opposing the
individual
so the word breaks that some dude was
killed by the cops
everybody takes a knee and they're
protesting and then someone's like wait
wait hold on
he's a white dude and then all of a
sudden i was like ah and they all leave
yeah so they don't think they really
care about police brutality
i think they that's a good point yeah
the issue is is it a popular narrative
well yeah exactly i mean i think
basically
when you say that they don't have an
ideology their ideology is to be
oppositional
to that which you know they've been
taught to think is wrong which is like
it's a very specific set of it's
tribalism
exactly and the reason i say that sorry
to interrupt is that
if if we were gonna say it's about black
lives matter and they don't there is not
concern about the white guys because
the race issue then they wouldn't have
been making fun of asian people for
years only to now change and act like
they care about asian people there's no
real ideology it's just whatever the
tribe
is is focused on now and it happens to
be black lives matter
it's griffin season well i mean by the
way like
the reason why i got into media is
because like during the 2003 invasion
of iraq it everybody was for the war in
iraq including cnn
msnbc because it was politically
incorrect not to be pro-military which
that manifested itself and you better
before the war or else
and so like if you look back to the news
coverage of that like you would have
expected those
networks you know to be oh well george
bush wants to do this and it's terrible
no
no not at all and think about the amount
of human suffering that resulted from
that i mean
where where are the who's asking the
media professionals who said that
we should go into iraq they get away
with all of it
so i think mostly what you see these
people the reason why they would say
walk away from a protest when they find
out the guy's white is because
it's just whatever the popular media
narrative is they're getting their cues
they're being told to do
bill maher had this really amazing
segment where he almost got it
it was hilarious where he was like
sensationalist
negative news coverage about covet is
making democrats insane
so there was a poll done new york times
published this asking
democrats republicans and independents
the
the likelihood of hospitalization for
coven what they thought it was
more than 50 percent i think 75 percent
of democrats got it wrong
and republicans got 26 republicans were
correct
and most of them got it wrong as well
but substantially less than democrats
and then 20
of independents and so bill maher's like
the media that democrats consume is
constantly negative and it's making them
crazy
but donald trump is bad that was true
that was all true
it's like okay dude's probably lying so
here's what happens you get people who
are sitting there bored with no purpose
and the media is like what can we say to
manipulate people into giving us money
and
getting us ad clicks pure porn is that
fearboard boom yup
exactly extrapolate that same thing to
the right which is like people's
perception
is one thing you know just sitting in in
their homes
and then all of a sudden it's like wait
a second you're telling me that
these aren't it's not a party-like
atmosphere and it's a and it's a and
then the thing is what they'll do is
like cnn or msnbc is you you'll watch
the news
segment and you get you get fed that
fear porn and as soon as the
commercial's hit
hey here's those paintings
that's an amazing point you're watching
cnn you're watching fox or whatever
and they're like there are people's
homes being burned down
children fired upon now we'll be back
after these messages
and then the drug commercials yeah like
if you're watching might as well be a
cigarette yeah
you'll be watching fox's sean hannity
then after that goes commercial and
he'll be larry elder he'll be like hey
does your back hurt like mine pop these
pills then the next commercial be like
hey did you take those pills
well you might be you might get a
conversation that's the point
they're both selling they're both
hocking the same products on on each
side
yeah and all that matters is you just
you just stay to that corporate
that party line as long as corporate
america is down with it you're good to
go i don't know
i got i will stop though and i think
brett bear and tucker carlson do a good
job
i think tucker leans but what happens to
those guys what happens to tucker
carlson
well i i went on tucker to say what i
saw in kenosha
right yeah and all i said was
rittenhouse told me this
i saw this and then cnn says my
supported the conservative claim that
rittenhouse acted in self-defense and i
said
i emailed him um okay you either
that's a misstatement that's that's
either had me on to correct the record
or prepare for court they had me on to
correct the record and they did good
journalism after that but
that's how it works they corrected it
they had me back on and they did a
longer segment with me yeah they did oh
that's cool yeah to their credit but i
just had it you know
i wouldn't have gotten on if i hadn't
literally threatened that
i'm not a big fan of fox news as a whole
but brett bear does a really good job
yeah
he's a great reporter and tucker carlson
leans into tribalism every so often
but he does i think tend to do a pretty
good job however i'm not a big fan of
ingram or hannity uh is doing a new
thing recently
i talked to him i thought he doesn't
okay i think regardless it's like
let those ideas be exposed to the
sunlight and
let them die there rather than okay who
is it who advertise on this program
okay you guys all advertise do you
support this specific statement that
they said this one time
otherwise you're done and that's but
listen there's no free speech anymore
cable news there's fox news and then
there's literally every other network
yep
and so fox yes in my opinion not great
individuals but like
i think greg gutfeld and the five yeah
do a really good job and i i really i i
am a fan of juan williams or at least
on fox news is the the anchors could
also have different ideologies on cnn
yes cnn nbc is like hey guys this is the
track
you guys are running and i think one
thing that really opened my not opened
my eyes but i think it was a good moment
for the american people to see was
when tucker carlson he was coming to the
end of his segment and it was when he
was bashing
amazon and jeff bezos and then he's
handing it off to sean hannity and you
can hear
sean hannity obviously he's hearing
tucker then he goes oh well we've we
support free market and capitalism you
just see tucker do that facebook yeah
yeah and i thought
that was actually a great moment for fox
because it shows hey we can at least
differ on these things be on the same
network
but it was by mistake hold on this is
why i said i'm a fan of juan williams
because
he he like they rag on him yeah i think
he's wrong
all the time like i'm sitting there
watching jesse laugh at him and i'm like
juan is wrong but i'm glad that he's
willing to be there with them
taking that punishment and and saying
what he believes with passion
some people think he fakes it i'm like
no the dude genuinely believes i think
that's
the point though is if if you appear on
either of these two
echo chambers then you are this so i was
trying to tell the american public one
thing
what i saw and it was an incredible
challenge
for me to navigate the landscape after
the shooting because
i had to basically i appeared on fox
first okay you're this
and it's like no no that's a
misstatement
here are the facts prepare for court or
have me on
i mean i say i say like got a threat
you gotta threaten i say a bunch of
wacky stuff on this show but will the
grifters on twitter ever take the clips
of me saying tax the rich
or police exactly you should resign they
won't do that they'll take the clips
that are like kylo ren's acted in
self-defense
and then they'll tell everyone on the
left tim poole is far right or whatever
and then the people actually watch the
show are like tim's a liberal all right
tim i have to say when you when i would
agree or
i'd agree i'd say i don't know what
you're being successful or not now
because
i know you've been doing this just like
i don't know what what would you call it
but i know when you're kind of sarcastic
but it's called gas lighting
i have consistently and always said i'm
in favor of a higher progressive tax
tax on yeah no that is true always
always and the reason i tweeted it
is because i was like i finally started
to notice and i never really cared that
much and i was like oh you know what's
happening
these these the manipulation machine the
media machine needs an enemy they need
to make money off this so they they
purposefully watch the show and ignore
all of like the normal like kind of
liberal positions i might hold
and then look for that one thing that's
kind of conservative yeah and then they
take that and they put it on twitter
that's
i was on a uh reality tv show actually
um it was
not very watched but it was 2016 called
them it was called
house divided it was on full screen
media i think they scrubbed it after
hillary
lost it was a big uh they don't need to
go there but
basically you sign a contract where you
can basically sign everything away like
it's like we can repurpose your content
for whatever to portray you as whatever
we want
so i went in there and i'm like you know
i'm uh
across the board you can't really put my
politics in a box very easily
and so i said you know i'd be a
libertarian who supports a lot of
kind of you know big government efforts
to even the playing field but that
doesn't fit in a box right so yeah i
said
oh they'd say what do you think about
this well the conservat conservative
movement blah blah blah blah oh what are
your politics i'm uh
like on camera in my interview then cut
to b-roll and then cut to me saying
conservative in a different instance
conservatives they did that oh yeah
yeah what do you think of this girl oh
she's really she's pretty she's super
nice
uh what do you think about the weather
outside it was super hot outside oh
she's
cut to b-roll hot so like i'm telling
you like no seriously in my contract
there's no recourse because the contract
you sign you sign it away
so by the way please everybody out there
don't go look this show up because
that's really bad what was the show
called again it's called
divided but it's like it just goes to
show how you can just take
p you say enough words you're on camera
for eight hours a day
they can choose whatever they want and
then use the power of editing to just
oh yeah portray whatever they want i
love it when there was one clip that
went viral of me where there was literal
jump cuts like
and because i was issuing caveats i was
like here's what i think
now keep in mind a b and c one two three
but with that said
exactly they cut out all the cabinets so
it's like me going like i think that
donald trump is the greatest
present ever joe biden is the worst
what's that what's that absolutely like
people were putting like famous people
they're like they'll be singing the song
like a
deep fake that scared the crap out of me
that's that's i think we're having oh
yeah yeah take a picture of you and make
it dance yeah that
oh i was like whatever man welcome to
the future coming fast
that might even be happening right now
we don't realize that like if the deep
state
or like you know the cia or like what
else is there boston dynamic these weird
like secret programs work because if we
if we
we know that it's pretty advanced that
the public sees that can only imagine
the stuff that's being worked on behind
the scenes there were pyramids
of pyramid-shaped objects flying over
u.s naval destruction but i heard they
couldn't find a base for these
pyramids they're actually triangles a
base
they couldn't look like a pyramid has a
base to it so that means it's
three-dimensional but we
i don't think they could see the
dimensions right so it's just triangles
right right because they have
gravitational warp speed
anything that you you see publicly they
got something way better yeah no
these we know confidential
confidentiality exists we know top
secret exists
we know there is you know classification
so that means when you see like here's
our latest robot
well there are secret things you don't
know about wait so which side of the
culture were are the aliens on then
because we just got a circle i would i
would honestly i was an anarchy
i would i would uh there's there's two
schools of thought on this
um the anna the aliens would be on the
side of the wok
because you look at like you've seen
rick and morty right yes
when the galactic federation takes over
earth everyone's forced to eat pills and
do
menial labor for the sake of just having
a job okay and so there's one
i shouldn't say there's two schools but
one idea is that they're on the side of
the woke because they need everyone to
be drone-like
and ideologically homogeneous so this is
a one-world system
the galactic federation can't work with
the united states so long as there's
fractured nation-states which
means the nationalists are certainly at
odds with any alien
and you know endeavor to communicate
with us because who would they negotiate
with
each different country get out of here
could you imagine if you were like we're
gonna go talk to russia and they had 10
presidents
you'd be like nah it's a waste of our
time get one president get out of it
what if they're interdimensional beings
though
well so the other idea but the other
idea is that they're anti-woke because
they're looking for
that they're looking to work with those
that are intellect intellectually
discerning
and can understand nuance and complex
thought and there's no point in engaging
with
a drone like species that's what i think
i mean i hope i guess
a star trek future with of of
enlightenment values as opposed to
borg like values you guys have a
practice reference psychic
psychic energy just like if we ever i
would say
out there cosmic energy cosmic energy
tell me it's a different thing
i mean people pick up on vibrations
that's why i have the mustache it's like
you pick up on yeah it's attached to
nerves electromagnetic vibrations
exactly why do cats have whiskers
they can sense energy exactly exactly
yeah yeah like apparently if you close
these off
they like did you ever see those wolves
that like
they they line up to magnetic north and
they're fox i think foxes and then they
they hunt
but they'll like line up to magnetic
north and then they'll they'll like
sense the
the rabbit and then they'll dive and
catch it in the snow
that's interesting yeah dude i just know
for humans
uh because i read it in thinking grow
rich and i think i've felt it a couple
times it's it's flow state yeah that's
like
that's like a normal thing for humans
it's it's you know like
you're shredding the gnar yeah shredding
the knot i think it's you cool your
frontal lobe
it's almost i don't know it's just like
you're in an intense focus yeah
and i mean i felt it when i was work i
feel like i've i felt him even in some
of like the chaotic scenes but yeah yeah
yeah oh it's in a flow state
things just click it's just a just one
of those
ego when when i used to cover riots time
slows down it's the greatest thing ever
yeah so people describe it as time
slowing down but i think i found a
better way to describe it at least for
me it's not that
time slowed down it kind of feels that
way like everything like you can just
see everything and you're moving really
quick and you're dodging but to me i
think the easy way to explain it
is that when you're normally looking at
something you're focused on a single
point and you have peripheral vision
which is kind of out of focus and you
can kind of sort of understand
but for me when i'd be in a riot and
some high intensity thing would happen
my all of my vision would become the
same focus
like peripheral vision my whole field of
vision would become crystal clear and i
could see everything perfectly as if it
was not peripheral
and that i think simulated some kind of
time slowing down
because your brain is processing
everything really really fast and at
once
so it's like you're seeing everything
and then you can make a move
it kind of feels like time slower that
was probably your uh flow state then tim
right
it's like getting barrel bruh it's like
getting barreled barrels it's like
getting shacked in a wave dude
yeah like all the water is coming over
you feel that like you're
you're you're out there and then also
you see like someone raise a weapon pull
a trigger and then all of a sudden
you're just like well i told the i mean
i
when i spoke to police after the
shooting i basically all of my
estimations on time were way over
because i was like oh i think i
interviewed him yeah i was like
40 minutes and maybe it was an hour it
was 15 minutes you know but there's so
many things leading up when you're
yeah i would think if time is a
perception of motion
then um if you're experiencing more
motion
that it would seem like less time was
happening i wonder if it's actually
the perception of time is based upon the
amount of information you're processing
so if you're experiencing something that
you've experienced a million times
before your brain disregards it
and then time starts speeding up the
older you get because your brain is
ignoring
making the coffee in the morning it
doesn't register anymore when you're
younger making that coffee for the first
or tenth time it's like relatively new
so when you're in a conflict zone every
your brain is basically like
in this circumstance we must process any
and all
process any and all information that
comes to us for the sake of our safety
time feels like it's going slower
because your brain is running
all of these calculations and not
ignoring anything
so it's like actually i guess a better
way to put it is that's the true
experience of time
when all of the information is coming
into your brain and then the way we
normally experience time is there's gaps
because we forget things that don't
matter
that's why like when i eat a big mac it
seems so quick exactly because your
brain doesn't care
so many times that's why people can't
remember what they had for breakfast
good it just happened so quick
it's gone but the first time you did a
big mess thought it was every bite
takes forever i still remember it
yeah no but like you asked people would
you have for breakfast yesterday and
they'll be like what did i ever
i can't remember because it is it
relevant yeah it's okay it's already
written
i bet i could ask you about what
happened in kenosha and you could
probably give me crazy details and
explain
all this crazy story you'll never for
never forget it that's that i mean
that's a very good point it's like
um i guess you know the amount of
details that stick out in your mind and
that
was the interesting part too after the
fact is like talking with the new york
times reporters and stitching together
all these different streams and he's
like
hey when you were running after kyle
like you stopped uh
like why did you stop there's something
fell on the ground and i was like
oh my god yeah i stopped because
my gas mask fell out of my bag because i
opened my gas mask bag
right before i saw kyle to break out a
white claw to defuse the situation with
these guys who wanted to smash my head
in
and so i didn't ever clip my gas mask
back in because i saw kyle running and
then i just ran after him
and you know like that kind of that kind
of stuff you don't forget
exactly but you forget what you had for
breakfast you know what i mean i mean
that figuratively like i don't know if
you remember what you have for breakfast
but
people forget like the little
nonsensical things that don't matter
but you're in that when you're in the
fray man everything is
so you think that's sorry sorry that's
why everyone said 2020
went uh actually this is weird 20 i
guess this is why everyone said 2020
went by so fast
because we were all sitting in our
apartments doing the same thing over and
over and over again
so everybody was like wow i can't
believe how how you know how
i feel like 2020 was like six seven
years something really
yeah i i see a lot of people tweeting
he's not doing the same thing every day
already december i can't believe it's
already like whoa where did this where
did this year go
i guess depending on who you were
because for a lot of people they never
experienced pandemic before so
everything was new
for a lot of other people locked in
their apartments everything was
redundant
like solitary confinement would seem
like a million years right
yeah i don't know i don't know maybe
it's just depends on the different
on different people because i've heard
both i guess you lose track of time you
don't realize
some people overestimate some people
underestimate yeah
i don't know yeah i i kind of agree with
you i feel like 2020 lasted longer than
a year i guess just because
all the commotion that we were in and um
yeah i think another interesting thing
too is when you're on the ground
obviously you have you know the flow
state but
you start to actually pick up on a lot
of tendencies um i think they
they've used the word tendencies in
sports more but you start to pick up
tendencies on protesters
agitators law enforcement um just little
knickknacks that you already know kind
of
you know you could kind of predict some
things before they pop up let's let's do
this
i i want to i do want to talk about some
cultural stuff in a bit but i want to do
one more because i want to i want to ask
you guys your thoughts on some on what's
going to happen but
first i want to pull up this story
because we only briefly mentioned it
governor waltz declares an emergency
he's bringing in police from ohio and
nebraska
you mentioned that the senate passed a
nine million dollar emergency fund
they're bringing in all these other
police
so the verdict is supposed to come soon
this this the state
is declaring an emergency at the
national guard already on scene
we don't know what the verdict is going
to be it's possible it's going to be a
hung jury because
that means they can't come to a decision
that seems possible
on the merits i've seen some legal
analysts say
it's not guilty across the board however
due to the politics
some people are saying either a hung
jury or guilty across the board
i've been i've been seeing the exact
same thing when i when i reach out to
like the professional like lawyer i
think you're you know like will
chamberlain
there's other great lawyers that are
like are doing great analysis
right now they don't see any way this
could be guilty
but one thing they've some of them have
mentioned said hey this thing is so
politicized that the jury just might
just do it anyway
um this whole thing and then um tim did
you get to see
um the prosecution's like last sentence
was like
oh um you guys say that george floyd
died because his heart was too big
uh you know uh he died because derek
schaumann's heart was too small which
was odd for me because it's like
on most on most final lines they they
end on like
a fact or something right this they go
off that but it kind of he
he more did it for like media i don't
know that's what i think i don't know
what you guys thought the most watched
trial in history i guess
well so so first i'll ask you guys i
don't know if you've been following
i've been following the court case but
you guys have been on the ground so i
don't know if you've been following a
lot of the trial stuff
but i'm curious what you guys think
based on what you've already seen based
on your experience what's coming next
what's going to happen in minnesota
richie i mean i don't think it really
matters honestly
i think verdict yeah and like we
actually
when we were on the ground last night in
brooklyn center
it i commented to jorge after the fact
it ended up being a completely peaceful
evening but at the beginning
like jorge was like inquiring to me like
you want to go live man and i was so
bugged out
by all the people all the anti-media
sentiment all the anti-corporation just
like
the anger in the crowd was so palpable
that jorge is like hitting me up and
like i knew that there was one of the
organizers in our area and i was just
like
or he was like wow rich is kind of being
a jerk but i just like was i was bugged
out that honestly
even me acknowledging him was gonna tip
people
everyone was just so mad that i don't
know i think it's a powder keg that has
nothing to do with the actual realities
of the case or anything like that it's
just
it's gonna pop off no matter what
happens because yeah and it's just like
lockdowns it's economics it's
well i politics i just want to add a
little bit i i agree with richard
because like when you talk to folks on
the ground
for them it's like if they don't hear
the word murder it just like doesn't
matter
and i think just i just think that no
matter what happens we're going to see
an
interruption um i'm going more off the
the like my
if it's like a prediction thing i
actually don't think the riots
are going to hit the magnitude that it
did last time i think last summer
too many factors rolled in coveted the
unemployment i mean i think
some people were making like 600 bucks
per week on another point i think all
that kind of factored into that
i don't know we could reach that um but
i agree which i just think
if for me if they don't hear the word
like murder in there
it's not it's not good but actually
there's there's no murderers
well they're second degree and three
others it's yeah i mean he's on trial
for murder
just not premeditated murder yeah so she
wants first degree i think
i think it's true it's it's a good point
to say that they're gonna say he was
never tried for the true crime of
first-degree murder
and so no matter what what um how well
of a job do you think eric nelson did
with derrick shaw do you think you think
he at least put it put a good case in
front of the jury where they
there's no i'll say this from my
personal opinion as someone who knows
nothing
you know who knows little about the law
relative any of these lawyers
i felt like the state failed to prove
its case they couldn't convince me
that like dude i made several videos
angry at shoving
when all this went down and i was like
this is crazy and i was like he
shouldn't have done this
and then i watched this trial and i'm
like they did nothing to prove
that chauvin caused the death of george
floyd they only gave me maybe
it happened this way in fact the
prosecution said at one point maybe it
was his enlarged heart maybe not
but chauvin and i'm like whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
maybe but by the way yeah it has to be
it doesn't
okay so in order to prove murder it has
to be beyond a reasonable doubt
that he intended to kill him in that
moment
in that space no it doesn't so i got
this wrong uh it's because they're doing
the felony murder rule
they're saying he had the he had to and
he had to have the intention to use
force against floyd for third for felony
assault
that floyd died from so it's this it's
the it's a it's the felony murder rule
so okay so if it's if you're attempting
felony assault then
they die as a result of it then it's
felony and for murder three the
the equivalent according to legal
insurrections analysis would be like
murder three is if you're shooting a gun
randomly into a crowd and you kill
somebody
like you're doing something that can
result in death but you weren't
targeting somebody
so i gotta be honest
or even the the the the charges tim we
were talking about that how like they
weren't even
you you were saying that they will
probably won't even get to 40 years
which is probably going to anger
you know this crowd they i watched the
defense
and i was shocked when i heard the
prosecution's own witness admit
derek chauvin could have used more force
even a taser if he wanted to
that was the state's witness on cross
saying this and as soon as i heard that
i was like okay i'm done
now now you need to tell me that you're
you're claiming he committed assault
against george floyd
and he could have legally used more
force than he did then how was what he
did a felony assault
he used less force and he was allowed to
as a cop i'm not happy it happened man
but if the cop if your own witness is
saying that
so so i'll say this the state did a bad
job
the defense did a pretty good job near
near the end the state started doing a
bit of a better job
hitting the points they needed to hit
and the defense slipped on their own
expert witness
but ultimately after looking at
everything it was just the state's own
witnesses
firing shots back at them and hurting
their case and
it looks like the defensive strategy the
whole time was to have a short
short case so that the state went for
several days then uh
the defense was substantially less i
think they only had like two or three
witnesses
but then they did like three hours of
closing arguments laying out all of the
cases i got to tell you man
the defense is closing arguments wow
it's uh
um for me it's beyond a reasonable doubt
but what i'm saying is
i have if it's reasonable doubt that he
committed a crime is all it takes for me
i i think they've actually proven
chauvin's innocence but is this
one case this particular example is it
just too politicized that the jury's
going to say you know what
we got to convict this guy because it's
either our life
or the cities or across the u.s i don't
know this one is a
is the city a city council woman
voted to fire the city manager and she
said it's because i was scared they
would retaliate against me
so i think the jury's sitting there and
they're and they're going like i don't
care about this guy
he's guilty no matter what anyone says
because i don't want to get shot
that's that's where i think they're at i
mean well i don't know
i don't know i mean at a certain point
like you said
i mean you're that's your civic duty
right and you're you've
whether you like it or not you've
stepped into that role like
am i gonna cater my what i saw in the
night of kenosha just because i feel
like
people want me to say one thing or
another like
no obviously not and like you
at a certain point you know
if you're serving you gotta you gotta
determine what role you're serving in
that particular situation
and if you're witness or if you're a
jury member you have to just do your
best and then
i mean i don't know if someone wants to
you know
if it were me on the jury and after
everything i've seen
i'd be saying not guilty um i could
probably be
convinced of maybe manslaughter like if
we had if someone if we if we argued
over one of the evidence and i heard
compelling case but i'd probably still
be leaning towards not guilty
and i'm not gonna i'm not gonna change
my views based on what antifa the left
or the media would say of me
i tweeted that you know the kyle written
on situation
convinced me to finally like was one of
the things that finally convinced me i
gotta vote for trump
because the way the media was lying and
portraying everything and demonizing
this this kid
who far from perfect but still it was
you know self-defense
if if the media is going to be i have no
comment on that obviously no for sure
for sure yeah but
for me that's what i felt like and then
trump pinned the tweet
and it became a talking point the white
house press corps was asking
the you know uh caitlyn mcinerney like
trump pinned this tweet
i'm gonna say what i think even if if
they're gonna smear me over it
yeah if antifa threatens me i'll exactly
i'll tell you this i gotta be honest
i'm the kind of person to where if one
of these antifa guys
or anybody threatens me i double down
yeah i'm like bring it
i've gotten i mean i've gotten that way
i've gotten them from both sides because
also i'm a victim in the criminal
complaint
so like the people who support
you know who are auntie kyle rittenhouse
have come after me because like oh
you know whatever this guy's a terrorist
blah blah blah and then the other side
is saying you're a wuss you know you're
not
you're not a victim and like i just i
just have to say
what i experienced you know in the
moment so like what and the prosecution
might take what i say and you know
make it to suit their role in this
situation adversarial relationship
it's you know it's really fascinating
watching a trial like this and you
really start to understand
framing perception perspective and
it's really it's really it's really
really interesting how the truth
can be massaged by both sides to fit
their needs and like how you can omit
certain information to change especially
when you're the guy stuck in
and i remember when i woke up i didn't
actually view my role like
very um i didn't you know think oh this
is really my duty to do it until
the next morning i saw a vice article
just saying open fire
um and that terminology like it's just
it's no concern for what happened on the
ground it was like okay
now okay i can't wait until the trial i
obviously have to say something before
but there's politics at play man
i i'd imagine you're gonna get a lot
more heat from the left
i don't know i i've honestly gotten a
lot of crap from
um from the right from the from the pro
kyle i i don't know
honestly like i don't really i don't
think it matters like who i'm getting
crap from
because i'm still gonna stay the same no
matter what it's pretty simple truth
it's just
what i saw and heard but at the same
time it has been
definitely an educational experience
that maybe i can talk about after the
trial
because until then i'm just gonna try my
best yeah i think there was
also two on the con right house there's
just that story i believe there was that
man who like worked
in the medical field and he like donated
like 10 bucks
into kyle renthouse and like a local
journalist was like we're doing an
investigation we're at his front door
and asking him about his donut it's like
dude it's 10 bucks i mean okay you know
you know i think
i think it was despicable if if it were
me though i don't know if the guy
answered him or whatever
if like a reporter knocked on my door
first i'd be like did you see the no
trespassing sign
like you can go but if it was a reporter
like we want to get a comment i i i have
left to hit me up for like ridiculous
stories
i answer them it's the best of my
abilities yeah exactly i think there's a
lot to be said for that
instead of shutting it down well i know
i see a lot of conservatives will be
like
no to a request for comment i had
someone hit me from a leftist smear
machine and i wrote him a book
like i wrote like 3 000 words yeah went
in depth and like bold things and i'm
like
i got all the time today to talk about
what i think so like here you go man
have at it
and i'm very respectful and nice i'm
like appreciate that you reached out and
gave me the opportunity to save my
piece and hope uh wish the best for you
and have a good day good stuff and then
but then
when people see that from that outlet
then that basically transcends that
gap that we're talking about that schism
between the two trenches like
what they do is when you supply them
with enough words
they can selectively pull you out
because that's why you got to fight that
battle like
i have basically been fighting that
battle to get you know my word out to
both sides and i think actually the
one piece that i'm most proud of came
out on the huffington post
and mary to her credit like basically
wrote this entire
article about rosenbaum's last moments
and just because of where
people perceived me as coming from
politically they didn't care about my
account of that but
you know those are the same people that
are supposed to be saying you know this
guy
died um and we should remember him
and so like that account of his last
moments i think is important to just
bring back bring people back to the
humanity of doesn't matter what this
guy's
ideology is it doesn't matter the fact
that he literally came from a mental
hospital
apparently right before he got shot and
then i had people
all over the place why did you try to
save that that
sexual pedo or why'd you try to it's
like dude if somebody's dying in front
of you that's the point it doesn't
matter what their ideology is this is
this is interesting though because the
defense in the chauvin trial pointed out
this is not about the perspective of a
doctor who's watched hundreds of hours
of footage for
for a year is that about the perspective
of you know individuals who showed up
after everything already happened and
then told you their experience it's the
perspective of the officer who was there
and what he felt what he perceived and
what he knew and derek chauvin is not
a you know cardiopulmonologist who
understands what a seizure is
his perspective is george floyd kicking
is a resisting arrest
now a doctor may watch that later and
say that was a seizure but how would a
street cop know that
for you when you see a guy shot he's on
the ground how are you supposed to know
what his history is
or where he came from all you know
there's a guy in front of me bleeding
i have no idea who the guy is he could
be a saint for all i know he could be a
local youth pastor
or you could be a you know a diddler
exactly and by the way
kyle kyle ran back up behind me after
the shooting
and i screamed at him to call 9-1-1 not
even concerned with who it was or
whatever
and then you know after the fact
realizing it's the guy who had he had a
gun right behind me but
my concern was like for one thing it's
humanity
yeah and you know i was like excuse me
what are your politics
uh it's like hindsight is 20 20. it's
like aoc when she lied about what
happened at the capitol
the fascinating thing about it she she
she told that story where she like hid
in her bathroom and she was like oh no
they got in the building
that story was clearly fabricated
because it included details you would
only know in hindsight
at the time that aoc went to you know at
the time she cited
was like you know just around 1 pm no
one had gotten any any buildings there
was no one even trying to get any
buildings
only because a day later we saw what
happened she now says
at that time i was scared they got in
the building because she's calling upon
the the
anger and the fear people had from the
building being breached but that morning
nobody knew that was going to happen
that's how you know she made it up
people often forget about situational
context
so they look at like the rittenhouse
thing and they're like why didn't you
why did you help that guy who's a bad
person you're like
you found that out like a month later
yeah i i'm there on the ground
i don't know if this guy's taking a
seizure i don't know if he's a criminal
i just know that there's a guy in front
of me who's resisting or i know this guy
in front of me who's hurt
and it's always easy for people in the
outside to say oh you should have done
this
should have done that until they're in
that moment and i think
i don't know if you want to maybe add on
this rich i think what maybe happened to
you was just fight or flight right i
think you know i mean there's
yeah there's no there was no time to
make any decisions and like
i don't know i mean i look back it's
like could i have done anything else to
yeah for me like knowing you know richie
pursley and and you know working under
him
you know to me when i heard that i was
like man like it feels good to
be associated with someone that is
willing to do that for someone like yeah
i was like i felt you know you feel a
moment probably hey i'm glad that like
to call him like my editor whatever
because to me that was like
you know when people ask me like what
would you do i'm like i'm out i mean i'm
out so i i don't think i could have done
the same thing so
i think it was it was a brave thing to
do and uh
yeah i thought i thought it was
something it didn't matter at the end of
the day you know
ultimately like is there anything that
could have been done
to save his life like
the toothpaste can't go back into the
tube but you just think to yourself like
why did that situation exist in the
first place and
the only thing that i can do from here
is to take that human experience and
actually you know try to express to
people that you know
like it's not just a video game and like
i've seen so many times when we have
these crazy situations unfolding in
front of us and people are just on their
phones
and they're just keen on like what the
next tweet is and like
at a certain point the game becomes
reality and it's like
people suffer and die as a result of
what we're seeing on the ground right
now
and it's not just people who die there
it's people who die as a result of the
narrative you know
that it's like how many people are
economically suffering because you know
this news outlet wants to push this
narrative or whatever
remember remember that video i think was
from portland where
someone got hit with a rubber bullet in
their leg and they had a
mild bruise with some bleeding and then
they're like
we gotta put on a tourniquet man turn a
kid medic and the kid the guy who got in
the leg is crying and he's like i don't
want to lose my leg and it's like
wow they think these kids think they're
playing tiddlywinks
when they're playing you know they're
playing for keeps they go out there and
they think like you need a tourniquet
man it's like dude
his leg was fine he was like bleeding a
little bit you put some gauze on it you
know
just put the bad bandage over it you're
fine but these people are going out
there thinking that
they're literally the resistance
fighting a war and
they're playing a game and then people
get hurt and then they
it's it's it's it's insane to me i guess
it's people without purpose
they wish they were the the you know
their grandparents or great grandparents
storming the beaches of normandy
when in fact they're just a bunch of
kids with umbrellas and they weigh 100
pounds soaking wet
and they think they're literally the
anti-fascist coalition
fighting the nazis yeah and they're not
i think i was on the ground
you know you know covering these events
and i think i forgot who i told it to
i'm like
you know cause you'll be somebody at
these events and then you know when they
do the speeches part
everyone wants to give their speech
everyone thinks that their speech is
going to make a difference i remember
turning into one of our
a fellow reporter i was like i'm like
why does everyone think they're malcolm
x bro
like everyone thinks everyone thinks
that like they're they're going to have
their malcolm x moment and i just think
it's it's that it's it's lost and i
think when when people see something
like this it's
tribal it makes them feel like they're
part of something maybe it feels like
they're
they're part of a revolution they're
going to overturn the the police state
but uh
what's the answer then like if those
people don't have purpose and they're
out there for those reasons and they
don't have anything else to turn to
then how do we fix that and like what
in our society can we like i don't know
how to fix that obviously but i think
the root problem goes back to the family
structure and
the home and i think i think as a
country
we need to do that too i think one of
the biggest mistakes that i think that
we made as a country is for example with
like women
we like now make it seem bad that if if
a woman wants to stay home and like
nurture her kids and just be a
stay-at-home mom and just raise like
three kids for them to be good citizens
we like look down upon that because now
it's like oh well while you're staying
home
you could be like out there you could be
a ceo of a company and you could be
doing this and i just think
that the whole system of not having that
family structure i think is leading
to a lot of these these these uh these
also like we
are in a current situation where even if
moms wanted to stay at home
for their kids they can't because wages
have stagnated for free
i agree and so that the point is is that
in this whole situation and that's why i
mentioned the fact that now that trump
is gone it's a whole different ball game
is because
just prior to that during the trump era
it was like well you're either
you're either for trump or you're not
and now that he's gone it's like wait a
second all the underlying problems that
caused people to go to the streets in
the first place on both sides of the
political spectrum
those all still exist and so like unless
we address those
then this will just cont everybody will
continue to dig deeper and deeper
so like i guess the only point is like
how do we
address those underlying problems in a
responsible manner in the media
because that's why we're here in my
opinion and i think i think you're right
i
think
it's a it's an economic problem i think
one of the biggest things that i think
on the right we just
they just failed to talk about i don't
know why france is like when someone on
the left comes out and says
we want free college people on the right
make fun of like oh my god look at this
guy who wants free college and blah blah
i paid my weight but it's just like
well if you look at college now we have
22 to 22 year old couples graduating
forty thousand and dead eighty thousand
sometimes more never had a job in their
exactly and now now that 22 year old
looks at his girlfriend and says hey
babe
i love you i want to get married i want
to have kids but we're both in that yeah
30. and i think yeah that there's a lot
of factors in it so yeah it's
complicated but i think
that's one of the systems that we need
to look at is is now younger people are
graduating with debt they're not having
kids i know we in the united states we
have a birth
birth rate problem and it's not helping
that's why i actually i just made it i
made a tweet
a week ago i know i'm probably gonna
roast it a little bit for us but i said
if you actually want to save the country
get married and
have five kids you actually are serving
your country if you do that yeah you're
five
mark that time code too cancel jorge
yeah
but i i do believe you know corporations
politics politicians they all have made
it harder for us to
have families have kids and i think
we're now seeing that destruction come
out
in society when it comes to riots and
protests and all the crime that we're
seeing that's why they're going into
schools though
they're going to schools with critical
race theory to make sure that even if
you have kids they're going to they're
going to indoctrinate them before
before you can yeah they want to keep
people confused uh and i want to say
i mean like the federal reserve we've
got to default on that interest to the
federal reserve and evolve our economy
to a cryptocurrency but i i got to say
ian when you bring up the federal
reserve
you're basically like imagine there's a
giant mechagodzilla
and you're pointing to one of his claws
on his finger going that's the problem
right there that one finger we're like
bro it's mecha godzilla yeah but if you
hit it with a laser it'll
it's uh will accelerate the heat and
then it will
send the whole thing into psychic shock
i don't i don't think so man there's
there's so much there's
it has many points the finger is one of
them it is a good point the federal
reserve is a broken system that
basically allows
special interests to extract the value
of the working class and the labor force
and then buy ridiculous things with it
we don't even know what they're doing
but the bigger problem is just before
you can even get to that
you got to deal with the fact that
mechagodzilla's got a force field the
media
how do you get people to actually you
know help you build the the powerful
laser to take out mechagodzilla's index
finger
i mean dude you got a pretty legit
operation here i mean that's testament
to the fact that
somebody who speaks the alternative you
know something that's beyond just like
the corporate talking points
rods from god the right the riot squad i
used to know austin
i can i can give jorge uh like one to
two sandwiches a week when he does a
real good job tacos please
who would you so in terms of like fox
news talking to you and cnn talking to
you about
what happened with written house where
do you think you're you were able to
like actually express the truth the best
on cnn after i threatened to sue them
the cnn gave you the best
opportunity after i threatened to sue
them i like that i'm serious
like it was only and it was the same guy
who did the original story and i give
him a lot of credit for coming back and
doing it but also i think you know
probably i don't really know what
happened behind the scenes but
probably somebody was like you screwed
this up you better not get a suit
now throw in independent media and out
of all the different
platforms that exist so i think that the
independent media has kind of
if you're if you're digital media right
then you're only as powerful as how many
views you get you're only as
relevant as how many retweets you get
that's why jorge
shelby and i and everybody at the caller
it's like yo
don't use terminology just to get likes
don't say just
exactly what your audience wants to hear
and in fact oftentimes we're doing quite
the opposite
but over time hopefully you know
that so i think i think the challenge is
you know i think it's hilarious the left
left just like you know would call me a
grifter but it's based upon their
pulling bunk clips i wish i would just
you know look there's so many people on
youtube who just say the most outrageous
shock stuff
and they get the biggest views and it
ain't my channel certainly there are
people who criticize
the titles i use but i'm like those are
my actual opinions man you know what i
mean
i'm not simply saying things for the
sake of you know
trying to build the biggest audience
otherwise i probably have a lot bigger
audience honestly i'd be playing
minecraft fortnite or some other modern
video game
which is family friendly just do this
exactly you open a private browser and
go to youtube and i assure you
people who are in politics i think for
the most part aren't drifting i think
they're they believe it they believe
wrong things and that could include
includes me
that includes progressives i think for
the most part most people in politics
aren't grifting
except for the corporate media that are
trying to get their foot in the door
i think independent media tends to be
all right at least
corporate media for sure is grifton
because they'll literally just get a pr
statement from the democratic party and
they'll just report it
so msnbc to me they just they're just pr
for the democratic party so
griffin season all day for the messages
but i mean i think it's actually and i
hear you know people say this all the
time like
oh you know corporate media they want
this or they want that
it's not to say that like because like
working at nbc and msnbc
i would say the real revealing thing was
that not the fact that like everything
is scripted per se
it's still live but if you step out of
line from those
you know you're on the be you're in the
b block right you're this guest and your
perspective is this
if you stray from that you say something
that was unpredictable to those
producers
buh-bye you'll never be on msnbc ever
again
and so it's like talked about yeah
exactly so it's like it's not that it's
like um you know you have zucker being
like you have to say this or else it's
like
really just it's the same thing that you
see with like people wanting to post
like
you know a black box on their instagram
it's like everybody else is doing it
and if i don't do it then i'm the
outcast and so
it's it's like self-policing it's not
like somebody has to stand up there and
say
do this where's punk rock gone man all
the like no seriously that's the daily
call
in your heart listen these punk bands
are like pro-establishment
i don't know if you guys noticed the the
bad religion oh yeah
that i made earlier i i think i made a
joke about it with rituals like it's
funny how like everyone back everyone
thinks they're part of the revolution
i'm like
amazon is on your side yeah everyone's
like oh the revolution will be televised
i'm like
amazon and netflix aren't on your side i
got to tell you when when bad religion
is on the side
of amazon something sounds like it'll be
a quick revolution if that's the case
be very quick quicker yeah please tell
me rage against the
machine
[Applause]
rage against the machine is on the side
of amazon
thank you i'm gonna do what you tell me
thank you i'm gonna do what you tell me
yeah yeah yeah
yeah it used to be fu i won't do it
you're telling me
yes sir yes i'll do what you tell me or
actually it's fu do what they tell you
oh that's worse yeah that's what it is
they're coming to your house they're
they're they're coming to your business
they're burning it down
they're not saying they're gonna do what
they're being told they're gonna say you
do what you're told or else
oh my god yeah man come on rachel that
was hilarious
better than that man we're growing up on
bulls on parade when when all these punk
bands
you know all of a sudden like pro
machine yeah yeah
there you go the machine one i guess i
don't know what punk is anymore
i think of it as just like
counterclockwise not even not even punk
too like
hip-hop and rap was super against
establishment man like back in the 90s
you had the nwa you have to please know
that and then now
it's like you know they're on amazon and
nike and it's like
what happened to hip hop hip hop used to
be so rebellious corporations figured it
out man you look at
you look at public enemy and the things
they were saying and the corporation's
like how can we stop these people
yelling at us i know we'll adopt their
message it won't hurt us
in the least bit and they'll have no
choice but to be like right yes we agree
and they have these rappers tap dancing
for joe biden that's exactly right in
the 90s they were chilling
well that's and i talked to my mom about
this
shout out to mom one more time um but
seriously though because
my parents lived through it they lived
in washington dc during the counter
culture movement of the late 60s and
early 70s
and but at that time were corporations
like support the anti-vietnam war
effort no they were not and so
at that time counterculture is a
critique on the mainstream right
but when the critique when
counterculture becomes the mainstream
then there's no critique it's just the
mainstream
so we're meta now like every the
critique is the mainstream now
so what ground do we have to stand on
collectively
we're also watching too richie's we're
watching the realignment happen in real
time you know back in the 90s or when
your parents
were growing up the left was anti-big
business
and you know they're corporations they
would you know that was me i was auntie
bush and now all of a sudden people are
like
the left in the 70s would be mad at the
wages that amazon is paying their
employees
now they're just happy that amazon puts
a black lives matter thing while they're
shipping a product
well on amazon prime but to be fair the
progressives don't like amazon
it's like the the the i like that
liberal neoliberal
uninitiated mindless democrat voters
because i'll tell you this i i that look
i don't care for the grifter
type you know i shouldn't say i
shouldn't say grifter i'm trying to be
nice but there's a lot of progressives
who seem to be tribalist
and and they will defend the neolib
mindless democrat voters
but there are some progressives pro-gun
anti-establishment
don't like joe biden i'm like we agree
on all that stuff so i'm not i'm not
going to argue with you you know what i
mean
like i don't know i mean we can argue
about economics as friends
and we can have a good time and then
celebrate that we're all armed to the
teeth and and
stand in opposition to the war machine
and the manipulation of massive
corporations
i'm cool with the professors on that one
and the concerns on that one i think the
libertarian
actually i'll put it this way there's a
phony meme from political compass memes
and it's the libertarian left and the
libertarian right and the libertarian
left says
defund the police and the libertarian
right smiling
and then the next one is him the
libertarian left grinning and saying
because they're racist
and the libertarian right getting angry
like dude yeah i don't care what your
reason is for it
you know what i mean i think the
libertarian right left they're both
when do you think i mean it's very clear
that the kind of populist left in the
populist right have
a much you know an anti-establishment
been to them which is like let's
let's reassess the way that you know we
do government etc
when are those two sides going to see
eye to eye because right now
what we're seeing is the left basically
being held hostage
by the fact that biden who's a centrist
was elected and now everyone's outside
the property wait a second no you're not
it's the media
no no no no the problem is high profile
leftists who are pro-2a in
anti-establishment
willing to capitulate to establishment
democrat voters
because they want power i i'm not going
to name these people but i tell you
power or approval they want power so
they don't like donald trump
the the populist left doesn't like the
idea of hard nationalist capitalism or
whatever
they want socialism so they feel it's
easier to
to topple joe biden than trump so they
align themselves with neolib
establishment democrat types
that's why that's why aoc votes for
nancy pelosi
if they were actually like look look
what marjorie taylor green's doing the
republicans hate her guts
she's like going nuclear she raised like
three million bucks yeah
it was massive and now she's trying to
get maxine waters uh booted
she's she's just absolutely like taking
a torch to the machine
yeah the republicans hate her guts for
it yeah majors being what aoc was
supposed to because aoc was supposed to
be anti-establishment forced to vote
medicare for all 15
minimum wage ain't getting none of that
so there's no force to vote
this is the problem i can look to some
of these leftists who are pro-2a
anti-establishment i'm like that's a
good start and then they're like but i
will always throw my hat in with the
establishment because it gets me power
i'm like okay
now we got a problem yeah i mean that's
a tale as old as time right there
it was like if you're you're you know
because i'm always speaking to
progressives but if you're a progressive
voter you want a 50
million wage universal health care and
all that stuff you you didn't get any of
it you didn't get it and and the
progressives that in washington dc
didn't even find or force the vote let's
let's pause
that's crazy the trump voters hate the
republicans
they hate they hate mitch mcconnell they
don't like lindsey graham they they call
mike pence a traitor
donald trump was aggressive and stormed
in and took over the republicans bernie
sanders stormed in and got
shoved down and the bernie sanders types
decided to agree with the democrats for
the sake of just
maintaining some kind of leverage and
the trump supporters took over
and then the republicans fought trump
agreed with russia gate
tried to get him out and then literally
it's interesting you say that because a
lot
during the 2016 election a lot of the
daily caller
uh subscribers followers were all uh
bernie supporters
but absolutely and it just it goes to
show that hillary clinton was kind of
ideologically representative of the
centrist establishment which is like
we'll just keep those wars going
and everything is fine we came we saw he
died
i think you also saw a generation of
voters on the left and right that said
well why would we keep voting for these
people they just shipped our jobs to
china my dad is now an opioid yeah we're
getting a divorce and our family is
breaking out
so that that that's the thing but for me
the reason why we're not seeing the
populace and the populace right come
more together than it already is
is because of media like i said if you
turn on fox
and anyone on that agrees with bernie
sanders on free education free health
care yeah
nazi and the communists yeah when it's
like yo when it comes to the health care
system big education
they're going to screw you over whether
you're a republican i don't know i don't
think tucker does that
i think fox has not tucker but i think
the majority
i think it's mostly the mainstream press
why is it that tucker is willing to have
an antifa why is it that
tucker has jimmy doron the koch brothers
the koch brothers and george soros very
much have the same
you know well koch brother sorry r.i.p
on the other koch brother it's
establishment politics
it's a combo of that and i think a
hormonal imbalance
in in society due to obesity it's like
the large
60 plus percent of americans are
considered obese since like the late 90s
it's like these they've people are under
mind control
they've become pawns to this system and
they're like going at each other
i never get more fired up and ready to
rip this thing down than when i'm
fasting
when i don't have enough when i come at
this from lack i
i get riled up i get the energy and
that's what we're missing that's where
punk rock is gone
why so why why is antifa burning the
system down they're well fed
well that's a tough question there's a
lot of different issues there's a whole
lot of times
but just on a real quick on a tip that
richie brought in the koch brothers if
you guys remember in 2015
when people would ernie would interview
bernie sanders about his 2016 run they
would say do you support open borders
bernie sanders said
absolutely not open boards is a big
establishment by the koch brothers
the thing is now he moved into a window
and i think bernie doesn't believe it
but he just has to say because he's on
that side now he has to say
uh you know i wasn't for that and but
even bernie said in his 2015 interviews
if we do open boards it hurts american
wages first that's right well how about
we jump over to super chats and see what
the audience has to say
so for all of you that are listening
make sure you smash that like button
share the podcast if you really like it
that really helps and subscribe and if
you're listening to itunes spotify leave
us a good review give us five stars
let's see we got
trip sucks says i have been pro a pro
graffiti writer for 15 years and i've
tagged 20 countries including antarctica
i'd love to help decorate a portion of
the skate park and give you all a demo
of how it's done what's the best method
to contact
pretty dope pitches at timcast.com
that's epic
should now be live for anybody who has
an idea we're taking pitches on movies
uh video games that's a lot harder to do
short films movies documentaries shows
and art projects but uh i will i will
advise you
we're gonna get a ton of emails and i
can only just say
serious pitches only because with all
due respect i'm trying to i want to be
nice because i really do appreciate
everybody's interested
we do get a lot of people who have no
relevant experience in many areas asking
to do jobs
that they can't do i mean i'm trying to
be
you know again with all due respect i
appreciate the interest in some of these
jobs but if you're someone who's like
not worked in media and you want to now
all of a sudden make a video
there's a lot you probably don't realize
you don't know and so
it's not as easy to do but you know i
think we're definitely uh um
accommodating for a lot of people so
pictures at tmks.com
all right tommy durgarian says amazing
content as always shout out for my
company level ride concepts message me
about
member decals i can make for you at
level ride concepts cool
all right let's see alex thomas says are
you avoiding talking about bitcloud
because you have your own site
you have being developed i don't know
what bitcloud is huh
christian jamaigochi and says tim i'm
seeing videos about the grind bar and
compound all over youtube
you're becoming dear deck 2.0 compu
complete with your own fantasy factory
in the mountains
keep on being awesome y'all a bunch of
videos are popping up about it yeah i
see i haven't seen it yeah they're
popping up the graphics
my friends the vlog is live it is cast
castle and you can find it very easily
on this youtube channel the community
section i linked to it
uh i don't think i if i don't know if i
set a url or anything i just made a
youtube channel like
you know it's actually i think it's a
really old youtube channel i just call
it cast castle then put a video on it
because you just start somewhere and uh
that might not be the name moving
forward probably not i just
i was like we filmed a vlog we're gonna
put it up this dude grind to the ground
bar
the other the other day we filmed uh we
have a race car that was 100 miles an
hour
and we literally jumped the whole garage
it was awesome
[Laughter]
how far did it go dude it went so far it
went 100 feet
it went way over it's a big garage not a
regular garage it's like a big garage
with a skateboard in it
and it just went multiple camera angles
it's gonna be fun we're gonna get that
up soon
yeah that was awesome that was yesterday
right dermy wormy says in regards to
falcon and winter soldiers you need to
talk to gary from nerd roddick
we will have a bonus segment coming up
where i will get into all of that stuff
because i have
i think falcon winter soldier is
actually nuanced and relatively
anti-woke
i do i think the that falcon is is
realizing the problems of racism from
anybody
and i'll i'll get into that we'll save
it for the bonus segment
all right let's see where we're at gore
child says timmy should clarify
you said maxine waters might be caused
to overturn the election at the trial
oh is that what i did you said oh really
we don't want to if
we don't want to interrupt you you're on
you're on one we didn't want to
interrupt you but oh
whoops it was like it was you said it
with so much conviction that there was
no
you know i was like yeah it's all good i
wonder if youtube's gonna understand i
just misspoke hopefully i think i can
answer your question about why these
antifa kids are rioting even though
they're not eating properly
i don't think they are hormonally
balanced because fasting you got to eat
healthy
and then stop eating for 16 hours and
these people
are probably like just eating crap maybe
or nuggets and don't have a good home
life so their psychology is all out of
whack vitamin d
the whole life he knows what i'm talking
about that's right
all right sonny james says tim i think
you're exactly right about fifth
generational warfare in regards to
foreign sponsored propaganda
however i think you're totally wrong
about the drone capture of uyghur men
taken to education camps i saw men being
drafted for the purpose of war
interesting well a lot of people uh
you don't really know what uh
what the video is we we just trust new
sources that's that video of like a
bunch of people in blue
yeah bradley l 5000 says tim
thanks for the dogecoin tip made a
little money guest suggested
david park and jack murphy the other
jack from team house podcast there's
another jack murphy
oh didn't realize there was more than
one both on at the same time
tomorrow is disclaimer jonathan drowned
says tim it's easy to run away when you
have a million
dollars to drop on a compound in the
middle of nowhere ian is at right for
once
i will i will i will just say nobody who
buys
back in the company a million dollar
property actually has a million dollars
when they talk about celebrities who
bought like a five million dollar
property they may have put
zero down zero percent down and they may
have gotten a crappy interest rate
everybody assumes that like i think
donald trump put it best he tells that
story where he like pointed to one of
his kids and said homeless guy
he's worth more than i am because
trump's liabilities were higher than his
assets
so people need to understand that and i
will also add i moved to los angeles
from chicago with 200
cash and no plan yeah this guy works
hard what are you trying to say
i started from the bottom now i'm here
that's right that's what i'm wearing
tell him tim you put the ground in you
came from the gutter get from the
trenches
i coast new jersey is definitely the
gutter i'll tell you that
icos8 says take out the dumb federal
reserve part and you might have an
interesting point ian
wait i want to think back to that so
when you were talking about
fighting the machine or whatever yeah
yeah reference defaulting on the
the interest to the federal reserve he
just came out straight swinging at the
federal government poverty is
a driving force of this and i think the
federal reserve is keeping us there with
their interest rates
interesting just delamar says yes they
are tim look what happened in kenosha
the kid is now going through court for
defending his community standing up
gets you beaten or jailed two options
let them loot
uh i can read that part yeah
yeah the options are very serious uh-oh
what's this
kaiser c says ian sun's getting real low
big guy come back to us good sir
another another news will of the people
was really good
i didn't get it gareth green says tim
and ian are at it again sorry i haven't
posted for months
i was spending nearly as much on super
chats as i made per month
you both sound like collectivist but i'm
more with tim death by starvation is the
default for all living things
yo part of me really is with you on this
like let him
just let him suffer i think about that a
lot like are humans a virus on this
planet and we just got to let it eat
itself
out or should we be stand up for these
ignorant fools
all right and help them survive human
beings are a disease
you know that i am a gorilla
like what do we do because if we give
people unlimited food are they just
going to eat themselves into into
starvation like are they going to just
overpopulate and then wipe out the
planet
is there is is starvation and death a
natural survival mechanism for our
species
i asked alex jones what'd he say well
because i i said look look at the great
reset stuff what if it's true
that we are like like yeast in you know
just eating the sugars and farting
ourselves to death
are we destined just to reach a point
where we just eventually
you know just just fought ourselves to
death maybe we do need some kind of
reset to kind of
stop humans from just eating until we we
explode
alex was like you know he's like it's
important question because i think about
this
all the time you know what how do you
balance
the the fact that we may be on a runaway
train to destroy civilization as we know
it
with the same fact that you can't be an
authoritarian wing nut
manipulating you know people and
stealing their rights it's like
it's a tough question man the problem is
i don't trust the people who tell me the
world is ending and the rip the
oceans are rising and they buy
beachfront property that's like the it's
like oh
look man if you really want to convince
me of all these problems like
we got to stop overpopulation because
global warming then you go and buy
beachfront property
kind of think you're lying to me about
this when you take a private jet to
europe for a conference
i'm not saying i think climate change
isn't a real problem i do think humans
contribute to
i just think they want to hold us down
and exploit the wealth and riches for
themselves that was one of the best
series that we did
ever on the daily caller vid squad was
uh walls across america
all these people are criticizing the
walls we went to their houses and filmed
how massive the walls were around their
homes we should do an
update for for barrio and john kerry on
their
beachfront property the the sea level is
what two feet there
we definitely got to reorganize the way
people live
and so we don't starve and like
overpopulate but
can we do that with stupid or ignorant
people
lining the so why are people like you're
saying
they're ignorant the wrong foods and now
they're just like
blind you know like zombies scriptures
and the media that's intentionally like
making them sheep for money to make them
but can you blame those people
i can't blame them but not the problem
itself isn't necessarily the reason
there's a problem but
you still have to eradicate the problem
often yeah but exactly but
the approach of eradicating the problem
rather than going to the root and
digging out the roots but i think
digging out the roots will kill the
problem as well so like what
yeah so how do we dig out the roots my
question yeah i don't know rather than
you can drop it off change
i don't know man this is this is the
same thing i go over
like i want to help these people because
that's my empathy but
i'm also a realist and and if people are
destroying themselves and the world with
them
what's the value of keeping them don't
you think like that um
you know the ebbs and flows of the
two-party system have a tendency to
oscillate between like
um you know chaos and order um
you know the creative and the
authoritarian like
so everybody in the 1960s was like oh my
god these kids are gonna be the death of
us and now those kids are boomers
right and now those kids are freaking
boomers so
how did the system course correct well i
think
like uh responsibility kicked in well
culture came around and politics is
downstream of culture
not to use that over rot breitbart quote
but it kind of is
and so reagan was elected after clint
eastwood became
the you know the cool strong alpha male
that archetype that male archetype in
the 1970s on the tail end of this
so i think what donald trump did was he
kind of like just
hijacked the entire political system and
before our culture was able to
able to course correct back in that
clint eastwood direction you know he
basically
hijacked it and now everyone's like oh
my god the whole thing's burning down
because
it's not a natural ebb and flow all
right well
super chance because of the media robert
yes says the world is going insane but
at least i have my dogecoin like a good
doggo
also i love the show use this super chat
to buy the team some doge
yeah i full disclosure i bought a bunch
of dosh get you
i got super chatters take me to vegas on
some doge i got i i'll see the new york
times with some doge yeah
i'll keep this kind of light but um
because i don't like
i i'm wary of the idea that you know a
lot of people watching you mention
you're buying something
i'll say this i've actually become
fairly confident in doge that's all i
can really say so i bought something
that you can tell no i'm not going to
elaborate any further on that all right
because i don't want to i i i want to
fully disclose i bought doge that's
that's what i'm trying to do it's a cute
dog i think it's funny
and i think humor is confidence send
your boy jorge to vegas on some dojo no
comment but i i will definitely do
something if doge goes up and
no i'm not saying this i think the joke
is showing people have confidence and
confidence
it's bringing people together yeah so i
i like it i bought some
all right let's see joshua san felipo
says
police are cool and all but where are
the local private militias and armed
private citizens standing defend life
liberty and property
i live in florida and i know what i'd be
doing if the riots were happening down
here
weren't there people doing that in
minnesota yeah i was gonna say well in
the brooklyn center there was people
that came out and defended businesses
after the first night so um those folks
did come out
they might not always get the media
attention that they deserve but they did
come out
they did uh defend those businesses but
like that's actually written house was
kind of like one of those people right
like a local militia and look how he got
raped not really militia
you know people coming out i guess you
could are you call it that but this has
to be malicious it could even just be
like even small business owners just
came out and defended their own little
business
all right this one's for you ian from a
fan with some criticism
thank you sarcadin says ian you're
awesome man i love what you bring to the
show
but i need you to work on knowing when
you are derailing a conversation
i think i think i do know something like
today i was like i am derailing right
now
come with me everyone he's like but what
about graffiti yeah can i make the
federal reserve come inside i talked
about aliens at one point
that was great the frontal lobe flow
state i want to go deeper
hey this is a good super chat dr deluna
says youtube is basically the
minneapolis of the video hosting
platforms
it still makes money off those who
choose to stay when's the move to alt
tech platform schedule
timcast.com has been up and running for
only a few months now and we are
actively
working on producing new content on that
platform
exclusively as well as some youtube
stuff because
we're not looking at in my opinion the
same thing as
we have a ride about to erupt in our
city it's going to burn to the ground
and you need to find a new place to live
we're looking at a massive cultural
shift with what youtube does
and what is important for a business so
i'll tell you this
youtube has proven itself an unsafe
place to do business 100
people who have dedicated their lives to
following youtube or i'm sorry their
careers to following youtube's rules
find themselves banned overnight for no
reason without understanding why
or they get strikes and then they're
accused of things you look at say
stephen crowder
he's followed the rules he's gotten into
it with youtube youtube's try taking him
down
but what happens when you dedicate a
decade to producing content for youtube
youtube says here the rules say you got
it and then eventually they change the
rules
and arbitrarily enforced taking you down
youtube is a is an unsafe place to run a
business so
we're setting up timcast.com and we've
repeatedly talked about
creating an open source subscription
service so
the issue is right now we're trying to
build something new
ian it's very exciting hit up hit up ian
if you want to talk about this open
source subscription service thing that
we've been talking about you can message
me on twitter
um we have an element chat room where
we've been hawking ideas
we actually have a meeting set up
tomorrow around 2 p.m eastern standard
time with a bunch of developers and
we're gonna
we're going to talk about the code that
we're going to use to build this you
know what you know what though
you mentioning that is i think it's
really encouraging to see the success of
uh news businesses putting things behind
a paywall because we created
daily caller patriots only small plug
right there
um but while we were traveling around
the country to cover these riots we
found that okay facebook comes up
picks up on the fact oh these guys are
in portland okay portland riots
demonetized so we can't monetize it on
youtube we can't monetize it on facebook
but what we can do is say hey patriots
we're gonna show you guys what's really
happening on the ground if you subscribe
subscribe to click and actually it's
it's actually allowed us to to fund
not only that content but content to
show the rest of america what's going on
now i want to just really quickly add
richie is
uh youtube has already this has been
proven they're hitting
independent uh independent news channels
or just news channels that they
don't like hitting them hard with
algorithms and you literally can't be
seen i mean
literally at our daily college thing we
have over 700 000
subscribers and i mean they're just
hitting us i mean
our videos are so hidden people always
send me messages like hey we don't see
anything on a daily
caller we don't see we we subscribe we
have to subscribe again so it is a thing
it's already been proven i know it's it
started with
jordan charlton at the status quo he's
actually a progressive on the left and a
lot of progressive on the left and i'll
fight for them
on the free speech i think but a lot of
news channels independent media is
getting hit
by the algorithm and a lot of these in a
progressive left
wing channels they cover this the six uh
the january six rides
they've sold footage to cnn and msnbc
yet they'll get demonetized
for the same footage i just want to
clarify um i apologize
youtube i don't about anything that
jorge just said
love you guys and when you go to the
daily callers videos hit the like button
because
then you'll be way more likely to see it
but you probably won't i love you
we got dave weisbrick he says tim bold
of you to tell city people to stand up
to writers regardless of the
consequences when you ran away to the
countryside
due to last year's riots i think i
repeatedly told people to leave
minneapolis over and over again because
i literally did
so you see people need to understand i'm
not arbitrarily being like people need
to do something no i literally was like
i'm not going to live in a place that
can't protect me so i left
because i don't want to be supporting
that the people of minneapolis could be
doing that they're not they're staying
there
the cops could be doing that they're not
they're staying there and then the
system comes for them
and kim potter gets thrown under the bus
and i'm like what did you think was
going to happen
running around with with you know
there's all these rioters and you think
they're going
i said it over and over again they're
knocking on each door going after people
and you're like
i'm the one house they'll skip and sure
enough they make it to your house
so i left and then what happened like a
week after we we leave riots erupted in
philly
yeah they didn't cross the bridge that
time we were there come on man we're
there
tell them tim you've been here since day
one for the trenches and i'm like shout
out to eli you got punched in the face
where are you going to live your life
man y'all coming at that tim like he
ain't been for the trenches
ben walker says meaning and purpose are
a person's best defense against
ideologies of any kind
highly recommend victor frankel's man
searching for a meeting
the concept of an existential vacuum
helps with understanding the position
many of these people are in good super
chat good super chat
wimplow says remember when bad religion
used to be punk oh
good super saiyan 3 i like that yeah
thank you i'm gonna do what you tell me
thank you i'm gonna do what you tell me
no fu you better do what they tell you
that's way worse you're right
i don't know i like the play one i don't
know
let's see eric miller if all cops are
bad then all blm are riders
i support neither but if blm the
organization doesn't want violence then
they have
the money to hire private security to
control the marchers but they don't do
you hear the squad hired a bunch of
private security yes
i love it shout out to uh henry rogers
daily caller he actually put out an
exclusive report with like
going through all the expenses of the
private security so so we got a super
chat from sword and scale many of you
may be familiar sword and scale is a
really popular
i think was it true crime podcast yes
how bad do you think it will get this
week
how many cities burned how many
businesses destroyed how many lives lost
thank you for everything you do tim
cheers cheers uh well quick prediction
like i think i mentioned already in the
show i think
no matter what happens we're gonna we're
gonna see some chaos erupt i don't see
it reaching the magnitude that it did uh
but
i think we're going to see some things
go down this week i don't even want to
think about it
i don't know man i kind of think it'll
be worse
i don't know i think i thought what's up
i don't even want to think about that
honestly first she's like let me tune
out yeah rusty quarters says hey timmy
ian what are your favorite commanders
for magic the gathering
oh i'm sorry i'm convinced you can use
someone's favorite like a political
compass for instance
everyone who chooses kalia is oh boy
it's hitler keep it up by the way um
my favorite commander is not urza
i know urza's op i know i know right
now it's the worst it's just two
dominoes you don't get it you
the deck i built is pure pure work
global chaos and control that's really
fun
that deck is fun to play against the
games end up lasting four hours and
everyone's just confused as to what the
rules are tim goes
he just starts laughing and he's like he
doesn't even care if he wins he's just
like throwing chaos on the boys like
i lose i basically lose yeah it's all
these costumes grip of chaos all targets
are random it's really funny and so all
of a sudden everyone's plans are just
thrown to the wind and i'm sitting there
laughing
and then eventually everyone's like we
have to stop tim the way i just the way
i view it is kind of like
there's everyone's in quicksand trying
to get to me to stop me from making the
quicksand in space so it's like
three-dimensional it's all around you
remember we were talking about earlier
about like
everybody being larpers like that
but we don't really play all that much
anymore to be honest we do
lately but i would like to we did
recently have an idea for a board game
maybe it exists but the idea is that
it's uh the game would be
a a a an orbital space station doing
experiments with
antimatter explodes or the reactor
detonates
creating and then freezing creating a
rift where there's
two dimensions like overlaid on each
other and they can
you can sort of see both that's fine and
so the board game would actually be
three-dimensional
with magnets where each character
you know like clue there's like you know
mr plum or whatever
professor plum there would actually be
two john smiths two jane does
but there's like universe a and universe
b and then certain universes have
certain components so like
that's kind of a general idea we have
for a board game we wanted to make but
they can't come into contact because
they'll annihilate each other like the
anti-particles so
yeah two two people two to the same
characters can't be in the same place at
the same time
just you know but then like an
electrical conduit will be shifted into
universe a
and then to open a door universe as a
switch to open the door universe b
so it would be a game where there would
be like components that move around so
basically like
what we were talking about you guys
being larping nerds earlier
let's see lord of nosgoth says tim the
problem in this country is folks like
your buddy ian
whoa yeah they are all too happy to lose
themselves in a web of moral relativism
and conspiracy
i'm not happy about it but it's the
philosophy is is dangerous dark and must
be done
dingus says tim i live in minneapolis
our mayoral and city council election is
coming
november both the state a.g and hennepin
county attorney elections were in 18 and
up again in 22.
voters may have also thought orange man
bad made people freak out more
you had a president who was like the
riots have to stop and you had a
president who was like my staff come on
man they're donating this and commonly
us was like
give me money to get the writers out and
people were like i'm gonna vote for the
lady who wants the riders to be out of
jail
sorry man i don't know but i hear you on
the mayoral stuff yeah for sure
we'll see well you know dude in the
minneapolis a.g keith ellison's
very left wing he's like a anti-fascist
oh keith ellison yeah so
hey no if you voted keith ellison then
you got to deal with that because he's
an antifa
all right joe sullivan says floyd case
is a reasonable doubt versus doubt issue
just because there is doubt doesn't
necessarily mean it's reasonable let's
face the truth they will come for
chauvin in the jails or the street
verdict is irrelevant for him just like
floyd you ain't wrong brother i don't
think anyone's yeah
arguing with that i don't think you're
wrong brother yeah man these super chats
is really fire tonight yeah
yeah guys is on point yeah yeah
danine s not asking for myself but at
some point would you consider
internships
you want people who already know how to
do stuff but they have to learn
somewhere
also i'd rather future journalists learn
from you than from the current college
system
we are already considering internships
the issue is great that's dope
yeah but i won't take interns that
actually do core functions i'm not i'm
not about that i think anybody who's
going to be doing
kind of like a menial task is going to
be getting paid right you know
all right if you're an intern and you
don't want to do a menial task
and not get paid for it richie
dailycaller.com email me
so i will give you you'll learn
everything but you will not you'll get a
sandwich a week
so i'm thinking school credit we might
have a couple interns whose job is to
literally just
hang out and like a literal internship
like actually hang out learn see how the
business operates
internships are typically like minimum
wage jobs where they just don't pay you
they're like we want you to do stuff and
we're not going to pay you i don't want
to do that yeah now we can have some
interns you got to skate you got to play
music
yeah my answer [ __ ] was a little bit
different they did my attention to right
it's way worse yeah yeah just
ask about what the internship entails
but i will say this though for those who
are looking for internships or they
might be in high school or college and
are looking into journal journalism
actually watch tim pool uh back in vice
that's actually when i was in high
school i watched him pull back and right
now he actually wouldn't even be on the
front lines
and then you dm me and i gave you a job
for one sandwich a week you just have to
get tear gas
every week no no no no i need i need two
tacos
two tacos i don't know if you're allowed
to do that but i guess you are because
you're you're
good if
[Laughter]
no comment never never summer 160 said
here's five dollars get iana snickers
matt volker says that's that's called
being angry ian somebody got this man of
snickers
never get more mad than when i'm
snickers or five bucks
i'm just talking about we need to bring
punk rock to the main we need to
confront ian just said i agree with that
on his mind it was like i'm gonna
use it guys i gotta read this okay jmill
says
the guest with the point break shirt on
looks like an attempt to create an
intelligent version of matthew
mcconaughey's character from dazed and
confused
yes all right all right all right yes
that was
richie these super chats are [ __ ] you
got a joint
all right justin says tim and ian any
interest in a maker community as part of
tim cast
allow makers to collab on projects with
like-minded people
oh no echo chamber i do woodworking
coding and i'm a cloud engineer i want
community to make things with y'all
uh should we build a building for a
hackerspace yeah we do need a building
off
off-site that's what we would need and
then you have to be part of the vlog
we could expand the uh the venue the
grind bar
i want another property maker space that
people can commute to and from yeah
maybe we get a commercial building for
or build something we need a piece of
property
you're going to be like uh tony stark
you should start making
maybe you can go underground in a garage
i
there's a lot more people have a lot
more money who are doing fun stuff like
jet packs
you'd be like the tony stark it's
airsoft it's really about fun
luke's thing i think he was the one who
wanted players we have a lot of people
that want to come
and a lot of potential space to get but
we need the funding
i mean so we don't i mean we it would
help
the issue so sign up at timcast.com yes
but graphene i say funding isn't the
issue is because i'm not going to let
investors come in and
derail you no direct funding to
teamcast.com is the best thing you can
do is help fund the organization
grassroots
and yeah we should buy makers or four
million dollar homes
bro we've we're going to be hiring news
editors and writers
i've been saying over and over again i'm
not going to be buying infinity pools or
doing dumb things
like we're going to be making content
building culture and funding tv shows
and movies and trying to
like you look at this like woke movie
system and comics and
games like nah we're just gonna fun
things we like here's what i say
you want to make a woke movie by all
means i got no beef you make a product
you do your thing i don't like it i'm
not gonna buy it hey i know i'll make my
own movie that i do like
and then if people like that they can
buy it so i'll tell you this
if i had a choice like people sign up
for timcast.com and money comes in
provide a choice between buying an
infinity pool or
buying the labor that creates awesome
articles
i would rather give someone a job and by
the way that the cost for that labor in
order to produce that video or that
article is cheaper now than it ever has
been
previously in human history i mean this
is like the printing press 2.0 like
people don't realize oh our speech is
getting censored all this stuff it's
still the internet
right you can still create your own
platform like i would i would rather
hire someone to go report on the ground
like you guys do then own an infinity
pool or something like that
because because i'll tell you this
you're you're you're at a party you know
everyone's drinking everyone's bragging
what's what's better look at my pool or
look at this award-winning journalism
that's changing the world i i gotta
please you guys we don't get no awards
let me tell you about that
i mean you know convince him to get the
pool
please you guys start super chatting him
tell him to get it
saying we need a hot tub i think if we
can soak in the water it will make us
more creative
and it will give us exercise healthy
brain
and i want to point out richie brought
up graphene i did and he's right about
that yeah
i like the way ian thinks thank you all
right thank you
all right let's just want to go swimming
in the pool yes
i want to go swimming i want to go
swimming in temples infinity war
but i have to clean it first i want to
participate but i don't want to get
canceled
just a couple more super chats kathy
mack says how are we to survive as a
country with no family value sense of
community or a higher power like after
death
we are now a country that only values
and encourages self-interest
we may be doomed by this path i agree
this is what i'm trying to think about
that's true i'm trying i'm trying it's
not even about necessarily in my opinion
i believe in higher power it's a belief
in each other do we care about our
community
to where when we hear that china is
attacking us we need to defend ourselves
no the people in this country are split
into political political sectarianism
part of what bothered me about trump and
i don't
hate him but is that he always you tend
to talk about being the best
and being the one and like i'm the best
i'm the best and i find that a team and
supporting your friends is like so
key if you can be part of a community
where you the people around you become
better and stronger that's the problem
though i feel like trump was actually
more like
we are the best like this country is the
best we're the alphas
i don't know i think the problem is it's
like digital versus reality which is
like
the you know the younger you are right
now the more important your digital
identity is right like as compared to
your actual
identity so whether or not you're a team
player you're me or you're awesome here
it's it's a matter of whether or not
you're awesome like are you awesome
in real life irl or are you awesome on
the internet and like what matters more
now
is that you're awesome on the internet
so it's like i don't know i coach these
kids and they're all they
they're all trying to like stay on their
phones and like maintain all these
digital relationships and we're sitting
at the table i'm like dude you're with
all
the hockey boys like why are we chilling
right now why is everybody
snapchatting a corner of one of their
eyes to six different girls
you coach fun you coach hockey yeah
oh that's awesome yeah hockey boys yeah
so stuff like shout out to the hockey
boys cheeton puck
all right let's see that's awesome
uh mojo maka's mojo
mac is mojo tim you need to buy an
infinity pool hot dog for the chickens
um maybe we do build a i think oh a mini
a little tiny they would love that tim i
think he means chickens but for a cold
water for something else but
for us i don't think that's what he
meant i i don't think the chickens would
like hot dogs
so they're babies and they're learning
how to do dirt baths and it's the
funniest thing ever
because they don't know what they're
doing and they're trying you know you
know dirt by this
the chickens dig little dirt holes and
then they start throwing dirt over
themselves and you know
wiggle around but they're like they're
they're still really young so they're
doing it wrong and they're just like
laying and like flopping around like i
thought a dirt bath was like when sal
you know puts it in the back
i used to think the infinity pool was a
pool with a waterfall
that constantly went for infinity that
never stopped but then i looked it up
and i saw it was when it goes off to the
horizon and
you can't tell where it ends we get ian
an infinity dirt bath instead of this
yeah
i will real infinity dirt bath bin full
of dirt
there you go you communist you get a
dirt bath all right well last one last
one we got sword and scale he says be
careful tim
we all know what happened to every
headquarters tony stark ever made
investing in america right now is
dangerous
maybe just buy more doge now i'm i'm
investing in um
fun stuff that's inspirational i want
people to
you know feel like they can accomplish
things and
judge people on the content of their
character the color of their skin you
know what i mean what happened to tony
stark's headquarters
like super villains well like they blow
up yeah bad guys blow him up
no but that's important like what you're
building is actually it's completely
different from
like any other kind of commodity that
you're providing which is like
it's the proof is only in the pudding of
like what you put out on the internet
in video you know or on in print it's
not like quantifiable you know built
this building
you know but it's important you know
it's weird to me is there so many people
who are very rich off of doing
commentary
and they they just like their
accomplishment is the fact that they're
rich
yeah they just have their show and i'm
like why don't you guys let your
millionaires you know like
hire a bunch of people to make more of
this plus it's so the dollar per minute
of video now
is so cheap that the network that you
can build with just
a little something that even a semblance
of an attempt to be independent
now sets you aside from the rest i think
that the reason they don't
is because it's challenging to build a
team it comes you really yeah quality
control
and personalities and managing
personalities
it requires a lot of listening yeah man
well that being said a lot of listening
is required over at timcast.com because
an exclusive segment is coming up for
our members only
in just a little bit so make sure you go
to timcast.com become a member
smash the like button on this video
subscribe thank you all so much for
helping us break a million this past
week it's been fantastic
the show is live monday friday at 8pm so
we're of course gonna be back tomorrow
you can follow me on all social media
platforms at tim cast and uh
yeah just uh seriously thank you guys
it's been it's been an
amazing ride my other youtube channels
are youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comcastnews and
the vlog is up i gotta make the channel
i guess but there's a video
and you can see what the house looks
like we kind of give a tour of
everything and that is
in the community tab of this is a link
to it's called cast castle we may
we may change the name i don't know but
uh you guys uh right squad you want to
shout anything out
richard i just want to give a shout out
to the daily caller vid squad
who everybody's working hard and uh my
social at rich mcginnis twice twins and
two asses on bikinis that's how the
irish spell it when a
good and drunk off whiskey my instagram
instagram is jorge ventura tv we have
all you know updates long form content
for live updates on like on the ground
real time vincero report
um you know just want to shout out all
the hard work and journalists out there
covering
the civil unrest they call our vet squad
but also a big shout out to tempu
because it's it's a big thing when
journalists like us who are on the
ground who are working hard to get this
info out
it's great when tim uses this platform
to to give us a platform to get this
information out to more people i think
that doesn't happen enough
in journalism so shout out to mr tim
new media
yo you can follow me at ian crossland i
am ian crossland at ian crossland.net
and i love you guys
tim richie jorge lydia you guys so rock
and you
are chilling right there listening right
now thank you i love it i love the
criticism and everything involved
it's hard please subscribe to my youtube
channel all right don't eat taco
okay all right jorge enough accents i
was just gonna say i really appreciate
what we're doing here i'm so excited
that we broke a million that was
something that i wanted for christmas
we were a little bit late i'm very no
i'm just kidding i'm very very happy
that we reached the point
um that we have a million subscribers
and still for what we're doing here and
i am sarah patchlids on twitter please
join me in my
quest to have more followers than
sourpatch kids on twitter
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com in about 45 minutes or so
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all there bye guys
you